for
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
round nine of the 2014 S field cup had
as a prize ending that proves one thing
fabulous Fabiano is human after playing
here car Nakamura into a corner Mr
Perfect missed a move and a chance for
his eighth victory in the tournament
meanwhile Magnus Carlson also felt that
he missed a clear win against Leana
aronian today Magnus Carlson and vaselin
too will be facing off and that will be
a key battle for second place in the
sinkfield cup meanwhile Fabiano Carana
is the 2014 singfield Cup champion final
day of this tournament will surely offer
more surprises and it all starts right
[Music]
now
hello and welcome to Lester's Sports Bar
and Grill in the Central West End in St
Louis for the final round of the
sinkfield cup we want to thank you for
joining us over the past two weeks
leading up to today's round 10 action I
am sitting at the table where the grand
Masters will gather for a press
conference concluding today's final
match and even though kowana is a lock
for first place there's still a lot of
money up for grabs so let's get the
action started and head to the studio
with Jen yaser and
Maurice thanks Taran welcome to the 2014
sinkfield cop and our final round our
final round has been a thrilling event
Jen that's right it's been really more
exciting than we possibly could have
imagined even yesterday when the games
were the openings were a little bit less
exciting um we had plenty of fun
watching the end games on foil Absolut
absolutely and even though this is the
last round and Fabiana Karana does have
a lock on the title a lot of intriguing
stories going on in this game that's
right leavon aronian entered this
tournament as the world's number two
player and he got Lea frogged during the
event so now leavon Aron and is number
three in the world today he plays uh
Fabiano getting a chance to reel him
back a little bit so this game to my
mind is vital of course for the tpr fa
it's huge uh he doesn't want to lose it
and in danger what is the greatest
tournament result ever now let's take a
look at the standing so we can really
see how dominant Fabiano car's
performance has been eight points for
the Italian ameran full three points
ahead of our world champion Magnus caran
then we have veln toov with four and a
half points also having a great
tournament and Maxim bash lra and lean
Ronan tied for fourth and hikaro
Nakamura in last place looking to bounce
back today with his first win of the
event and today's matches we've got
Nakamura playing against Maxine bashier
lra topov vers Carlson and aonan vers
our tournament winner Fabiano carolana
Maurice what do you think today has in
store for us more exciting
chess of course more exciting chess
these players have been battling it out
so far for nine rounds but it's the 10th
round that's the money round Fabiano
Carano of course wants to have his place
in history as the greatest tournament
performance ever but in the meantime
there's a world championship battle that
is Magnus Carlson and former world
champion veline topalov who are going
head to head for second place who would
have thought veline topalov when he
started this tournament 0 and2 would be
able to take second place with a victory
in round 10 an incredible comeback by
him but he's facing off against number
one in the world Magnus Carlson their
head-to-head matchup not favorable for
veline 8 to3 in favor of the young
Champion it's going to be a war today
both of these players are serious when
it comes to battling for victory and you
know mag after being disgusted yesterday
was is definitely wanting to win today
to prove that he indeed is the number
one player in the world for a reason
despite the fact that he'll have to
settle for second place in this
tournament so with round 10 all set to
get started there's all to play for
history in the making second place and
players wanting to show that they do
belong in the top 10 and this the
strongest Tournament of all time back to
you Jen and Yas thank you
mace wow and we go to a packed house
here at the St Louis chess club where
it's a Saturday Maxim bashier leav
arriving to the game the top player in
France shaking sunil's hand Sunil The
Stepfather ofar Nakamura and a famous
chess coach as well the legend pardon me
the legendary Alexander bosski following
uh nextx that's right and then we've
also got hikaro Nakamura Us number one
and if today he wins he at least is not
in pure last he'll be tied for fth
through sixth place well there are many
intriguing stories about this final
battle of today uh hikaro Nakamura I
can't remember a single event where this
extreme young man America's number one
hasn't won at least one game in his many
stored Cher extreme ups and downs I've
seen him go through winning streaks the
likes of which uh fer would be proud it
seems like a compliment everybody wants
to be an extreme man right sounds like a
deodorant commercial or something but
Hikaru is a fabulous fighter and uh to
to today he needs that win to get the
the disappointment of a poor tournament
behind him and again to keep his streak
alive of at least winning one game in
every tournament he's played yeah so
this will be
definitely a battle to to follow closely
um we've got also All Eyes Of course are
going to be on karan's game as well he's
playing Black against leavon aronian
exactly and again uh before the
tournament leavon number two in the
world that that uh place has been yanked
away from him and the sea change that
we've witnessed by Fabiano's
unbelievable performance uh leavon Ron
and with white would love to settle the
score of the sinkfield 2014 with a win
and spoil what has been an outstanding
achievement by Fabiana well and also
that gap between the two is partly
because leavon hasn't been having a
great tournament himself so it's a
faviano success and also his lack
thereof that it has made just such a
vast difference between the ratings when
Leon actually came into this tournament
as the higher rated player vesselin toov
vers Magnus Carlson what do you predict
there from the opening cuz you know with
vesselin it can really go either way
can't it but he needs to win this game
in order to have a chance of getting
second place exactly well again uh
Magnus Carlson the highest rated player
in the history of Chess number one on
the all-time ELO list the man you're
looking at vesselin topof has been
number five now although vesselin has uh
three wins and eight losses to Magnus
Carlson for the
uh last five decisive games between them
were were made with the white pieces so
vessel and topof having white today
knows he's in for a really big match as
the world champion Magnus and here he is
with his Swagger Magnus
Carlson followed by his father Enrique I
believe and of course followed also by
Norway TV exactly and they're he's
trying to fight his way into the
tournament Hall that's pack it's
autographs after and it does seem that I
mean the Midwest is no known for being
courteous the people here are courteous
and you notice that nobody's asking him
nobody dares ask him for the autograph
before the game they wait till after the
game absolutely I mean they're in
Showtime mode I mean they've got on
their their game faces so to speak well
especially when he's kind of running
late there's only two minutes to go it'
be one thing if he was like NBL they are
10 minutes in advance exactly you know
they can see he's uh he's just running
up against it here and what do you
protect in this opening oh we do see
Genie singfield the audience as well Dr
jeie singfield one of the founders here
of a St Louis CH Club
witnessing um the creation yeah what
what they indeed what they have created
talking with the Arbiter Chief Arbiter K
Chris bird and the players settling in
the opening uh I'm thinking that leavon
uh pardon me not leavon but vesselin is
going to play one D4 I don't think he's
I mean he can play E4 but I I don't
think he's um ready to uh refute
magnus's uh King pwn defense ruy Lopez
and our tournament champion the last to
arrive kind of running a little
bit running late he is the champ but of
course he was not happy with the failing
to to win yesterday it was a
disappointment I think I think it was
even harder because it didn't clinch
victory in the tournament the tournament
was already over and what's going to be
key for Fabiano if he wants to contest
Magnus Carlson's number one ranking is
can I continually do this can I continue
to play at this level obviously you're
not always winning but at this level of
acsa so yesterday is disappointing in
that respect I think that if the answer
is no then how can he be number one well
his consistency has been simply
extraordinary through uh the seven
rounds okay two slips in rounds eight
and N but his tpr is just so far off the
chart it's been an extraordinary event
for Fabiano uh has fatigue played uh a
factor uh will he regain his energy uh
for this the last round lots of
questions about to be answered well one
thing that we can note about Magnus
Carlson is he's really obsessed with
Sports and Fitness I know that Fabiano
likes to swim and he's also all the top
players are into fitness but most of
them not the level of Magna so I wonder
if that really plays a role in his
unbelievable consistency and stamina in
these tournaments well exactly of of a
sound mind and sound body a Fit Body um
all of the players actually seem to be
in very good physical shape ab of course
they're all very young uh only vessel
and Toof is the veteran at 38 but also
is in great shape but I think Magnus
kind of takes the cake like he's really
into it yeah he if you give him a free
day it's like whether or not it's going
to be tennis or basketball or both or
soccer
yeah yeah exactly it's not a question of
if it's a question of which really
yeah and again a very intriguing story
about the game between vesselin topolov
and Magnus Carlson Magnus Carlson in a
very recent interview that was posted on
chess.com
um said this and it was wi streak
alive now I know we said in the intro
here that we oh and uh we do have a
little visual of that he's finished plus
two in his last 20 consecutive major
tournaments currently plus one in the S
cup must win today to keep the streak
alive will we talked earlier about how
we're going to have surprises for you of
course we have a singfield Cup champion
but one big surprise that you guys
should keep your ears on this broadcast
is that we are going to have Gary casar
calling in in about an hour so actually
an hour maybe a little over an hour hour
and 15 and so you're going to want to
stay tuned so you don't want to miss
that I it would be very interesting to
get Gary's Reflections on this event and
what Pana has done and there goes the
bell and Genie singfield ringing the
bell to start the final round of her
namesake tournament this in field cup
Knight F3 by leavon on his opening move
a flexible one but usually one that
leads to D2 D4 openings and I believe we
have seen E4 by vesselin topalov I was
leaning towards D4 U because I didn't
know if velyn had come prepared for
something against Magnus is ruy Lopez
defense right so he seems like he's
ready to face the Berlin but will Magnus
go into a Berlin that's the question and
and it looks like he has and the answer
is yes indeed so today we do see the
Berlin which we noted in many rounds uh
wasn't as present as we expected but
lately it's been making a comeback in
the singfield cup right right um not
only did topala play it against ykaro
but we also saw hikaro play it in the
next round against Fabiano Carana right
and in that game Fabiano played a really
really nice game to build up a winning
position one that he let slip just at
the time control by the way yeah I just
so sad because it was such a picturesque
uh finale there that he could have um
constructed so what can you do though I
mean you got to be a fan of both of
these guys from most of our American
audience uh it's really one homegrown
American versus another even though
Fabiano plays for Italy obviously a very
inspiring result here and then meanwhile
hikaro Nakamura the you know us number
one for so many years now um and with
his kind of swashbuckling style and his
personality which he always says exactly
what he's on his mind right you kind of
have to keep your eyes glued whether or
not you're a
fan personally I like it I I mean I've I
always admired Muhammad Ali I am the
greatest and he but he backed it up and
F uh pardon me in this particular uh
tournament uh Hikaru has not been able
to back up his Swagger not yet but it's
it's a little harder to back up the
Swagger when you're playing in the
strongest Tournament of all time right
true that that's just what they say that
the great thing about chass or the
annoying thing about chass depending on
how you look at it is that there's
always somebody better than you and
there's already somebody worse than you
right no matter who you are you can
always find somebody you can beat and
you can always find somebody you can
lose to unless you are Magnus Carlson
and the world champion exactly we do
have the Berlin ending featured in this
uh critical fight for the second place
uh yesterday we saw uh Fabiano building
up his position like I mentioned getting
into a one position uh Fabiano uh like
the H2 H3 ideas Knight C3 is the
standard move and uh still the players
are in theory let's go around the horn a
little bit let us and I was just
thinking of something so we know the
best chess player in the world Magnus
Carlson Fabiano making a little run for
it in this tournament um but how do we
know who the worst player in the world
is there is no worst player in the world
right you just wouldn't be able to know
you wouldn't be able to know it be
impossible it's impossible to measure
because if they knew how to play chess
they'd be by definition not the worst
exactly so you'd basically have to take
like a subset of people who already knew
how to play and then determine the worst
of those players so tough task you can
be the best but you can't be the worst
there you go good good to know and in
the game between hikaro Nakamura and uh
Maxine again I think that this is a a
very important uh turn uh game for
hikaro very disappointing result he
really wants to go out a winner oh and
we look we do see a cilian an opening
that has been Tred out several times at
this tournament and now he's played the
aru himself he likes to play the nidorf
lots of lots of uh moves in this
particular position my goodness books
have been written about this specific
position the very quiet H2 H3 the idea
here is to play G2 G4 kind of getting a
Carz attack swinging your Bishop to G2
and getting a a key grip over the D5
square but that's got to be one of the
I mean I think there's about six moves
that are more popular than that move
right we've got the super sharp Bishop
G5 the sharp Bishop E3 the sharp Bishop
C4 that Bobby fiser loves the bishop G5
is long considered the main line Bishop
E3 so-called English attack those two
are probably singularly the most popular
moves and then the Bobby fiser variation
with Bishop C4 what Bobby used for a
number of outstanding victories now
there's also the quiet Bishop E2 and
there's F3 um which often transposes
into Bishop B3 lines so I think right
there we have one two three four five
now you're pointing out yeah we've got
about six moves that I believe are more
popular than H3 although rie1 and H3
might be pretty close probably H3 is a
slightly more uh favorite but the idea
of Rook G1 a move Champion by uh
Alexander shabalov US champion and many
others is this move Rook G1 again
seeking this kind of a caras uh attack
where you go G2 G4 a lot of similarities
H2
H3 probably one of the more restrained
uh ways of meeting the Nar actually
against H3 and you may like this I
actually like transposing back into a
sicilian Dragon because now that whole
H4 sack saac mate uh doesn't uh crop up
on the board so I mean personally H3 is
obviously not the most useful move
against the dragon but neither is A6 we
don't always have A6 when we play Dragon
structures but between the two I
definitely would pick A6 yeah as being a
little bit more useful a little bit more
useful because there are some lines of
the Dragon where we play that move um
whereas H3 is just exceedingly rare in
the white side of the Dragon unless
you're playing like a weird line where
you're playing Bishop C4 and Castle King
side but that's not very testing to say
the least exactly uh uh flipping back to
our fight for second uh we do have again
this Berlin ending that has been very
topical at the highest levels H3 again a
move that Fabian caran amongst others
viswan thand uh enjoys and so instead of
E7 which we saw yesterday right King E8
um well what to say many many flexible
moves for black king E8 Knight C3 and B7
B6 a little bit of a surprise uh nor
normally when you're playing for B7 B6
ideas strangely enough your Bishop
usually is on D7 or E6 and you're you
use the B7 Square for your king So
playing B7 B6 this early when your
King's still in the center uh strikes me
as a little bit offbeat we'll get
Maurice uh to uh tell us the popularity
of B6 in that particular position now
Bishop F4 this is a very concrete idea
by vesselin well veln is thinking is hey
Black's King is in the center if I could
play the move E5 E6 force uh the move
let me just play a move for black so I
can at least point out what I'm about to
show is that um while the pawn structure
is very symmetrical and black has the
two Bishops the reality is that Black's
King is stuck in the center of the board
and white can try to use the the E open
E file to uh create some very nice
tactical opportunities here so Bishop F4
uh is a very concrete idea of opening up
the position we do not we don't see the
move Bishop E7 instead Magnus Carlson
has uh played for Bishop before a move
that we saw that Hikaru played yesterday
with the idea of capturing this Knight
and forcing uh Queen side weaknesses
since there's no Rook on E1 by the way
this move really do seem to encourage
the uh jump Knight E4 in the center of
the board I think that uh What uh Magnus
has in mind is a very concrete idea of
attacking The Rook on F1 and forcing it
to a less comfortable uh position so
still very
uh very interesting twists on this
Berlin ending which has been such a
difficult animal animal for the top
players to get their grippers on now uh
about that exciting Sicilian that we
have on top today um he car actually
played this line with both colors both
with white and with black okay um with
black he played it against a n and with
white he played against
vanu so he's a lot of experience then
with both uh both colors that's right
and this game's actually following that
an non game that he played E7 E5
attacking White's Knight white uh Hikaru
not playing your recommended G6 which I
love okay uh drop back with the Knight
then H7 H5 basically what black is
saying is I'm taking your your threat of
G2 G4 very seriously so I'm going to put
a stop to that he played H5 Bishop G5 by
hikaro the drawback of this pawn move to
E5 has been to create an outpost a weak
Square in the center of the board that
can no longer be defended defended by a
pawn so Bishop G5 pinning this Knight
that defends D5 Bishop E6 quick capture
by uh Hikaru recapture with the queen
Knight D5 beautiful Knight in the center
of the board uh players with great
experience love to have these big
outposts that's a big Outpost for the
night the other night comes up to C3
supporting the Knight G7
G6 wow intriguing move I thought that
black might consider the idea of Knight
C6 to D4 getting an outpost for himself
G6 Bishop C4 uh Bobby Fischer's uh move
against the um naidorf uh bringing his
Bishop to the A2 diagonal the ideal
Square D5 and again I think we're up to
date with the players no a few more
moves still have been played Bishop
H6 would where is that Bishop going just
stopping white from castling long uh
hicaro castled short and we have castles
castles and the making of a very intense
strategic battle going on here between
Maxim and hikaro and this is still
following the Anan game with the
exception of the fact that the moves
Knight D7 and A4 are not inserted so we
had this position in um hikaro playing
Black against an n and hikaro played D7
H6 he I somehow Knight D7 and A4 were
inserted into in an earlier position so
you could just play Knight D7 A4 and
then Bishop H6 and we would have got in
this position instead and then we would
transposed to a game uh from hikaru's
career exactly interesting position rich
with strategic uh ideas for both sides
black has the two B's Bishop on E7
Bishop on H6 considered an advantage
white has his
uh iron grip on the D5 Outpost as uh
compensation who's whose idea is better
I'm not sure now it's interesting to
compare the fact that we don't have
those moves inserted how does that
change things can black try to just play
B5 is there any reason why our Knight on
C6 would be well placed I mean normally
in the night off our Knight is is more
happy on is happier rather on D7 but um
I'm trying to think about differences
because it seems like Maxim vaj lra is
playing quickly no doubt aware of that
theory and of that particular game right
especially since searo has played H3
against the nidorf before so exactly he
had to be on his uh hit list for today
well one of the a small drawback well a
clear drawback of the move B7 B5 in this
specific position gen is that after
Bishop B3 this Knight on D5 actually
controls the square B4 and that's
meaningful for the following reason in
case of castles probably a very poor
move A2 A4 and White's going to get a
favorable uh trade of Pawns on the queen
side that's right so that B5 Pawn
actually becomes a weakness rather than
strength and I mean that particularly
meant since we've already developed our
Bishop on E6 it's not like we need to
play B5 to follow it up with Bishop B7
so the negatives outweigh the positives
there um kind of similar to the Roy
Lopez well where white kind of provokes
black into playing A6 B5 in a way so
that later in the game he can use the B5
Pawn as a Target in this particular case
normally speaking the whole idea the
Sicilian of playing B5 B4 is to boot
this Knight on C3 out of the way so you
can snap this Pawn on e4 since black has
no piece attacking the pawn on e4
necessarily charging with the B Pawn not
that effective so we have seen in fact
castles and and now Bishop to B3 by
Nakamura is getting that Bishop out of
the way right away now this is also
following a key grandmas game between
paragua and a St Louis Webster student
lwang Liam yes from Vietnam uh yes from
Vietnam Vietnam and now studying at
Webster exactly and a very high rated
player as well actually was the
alternate for last year singfield cups
since then Wesley so has surpassed him
right but last year I think he was
actually slightly higher rated and so he
was um the alternate player for this
tournament in case somebody had to drop
out um Wesley was this year's alternate
Wesley slow from Webster ready to step
in and this year and this year um laang
Liam is actually on the St Louis Arch
Bishops one of the nice things about the
US chess League which my brother founded
shout out is that these players they
don't mind playing and even though they
sometimes play it's much lower rated
players because it's not rated normally
it's good if tournaments are rated but
occasionally when you're dealing with
those Superstars and you're dealing with
lower rated players in the pool right
that freaks them out what do you think
of that it's it's always been very
difficult to play against somebody
extremely lower rated because the higher
rated player risks so much uh especially
since ELO ratings um are key to
receiving invitations so it's a big risk
from the from the perspective of the top
professional player but on the other
hand it's fun to be a part of a team
it's fun to play chess and you do have
to stay in shape so um pluses and
minuses there indeed it is kind of an
interesting issue you know nakur even
played in the US chess League several
times several times over it last 10e
history and I'm pretty sure that if it
was rated he wouldn't have been able to
justify it CU this when he was already a
lead player right he exactly so I'm just
thinking after Bishop B3 we're likely to
see a move like Knight C6 by Maxine the
idea is to bring the Knight to D4
pressuring this bishop giving him the
opportunity to capture I was looking at
a very forcing sharp line F4 now most
likely black should actually just trade
in this situation but I was checking out
this funny line Knight D4
F5 trying to blast open on the on the
queen king side with takes Queen takes
H5 I don't know if White's Landing with
any any force over there because there
is this crazy move Queen G good
defensive move I should say with Queen
G5
and it's a wild uh turbulent game
speaking of wild turbulent things um I
did get a one tweet from one of our
listeners at the hashtag sync cup that
he's going to spend Saturday night
stunning the Berlin
defense that is dedication is going to
spend Saturday night studying the one of
our fans oh wonderful wonderful yeah I
mean it's it's Amer night anyway you
should be going out on other nights of
the week but um I just thought it was
funny that they picked the Berlin
instead of the uh the Sicilian or
something right exactly study the Berlin
there you go and by the
way let's take a look at Fabiana Kiana's
game because we haven't really uh
followed what is uh Tak tournament
leader we got a little bit excited by
that Sicilian okay so we had the opening
move Knight F3 C5 inviting lvon by the
way to play an open Sicilian with white
if he would like to instead we see a
symmetrical English and uh four nights
English G2 G3 uh the second most popular
move I I think by far normally speaking
white plays D2 D4 at this moment but G2
G3 D7 D5 uh the defense that caruana has
favored uh a lot uh in his career D4 by
white okay now things are beginning to
and suddenly we have a tares defense E7
E6 so the tares usually not seen at the
highest levels
um uh defense that hearkens back to the
1940s takes on D5 Knight takes D5 I
think this is a very good idea to take
trade off a pair of knights so we're
about to see there it goes another pair
of knights and this is the difference
with the bishop uh check now Bishop
D2 uh it drops the pawn because after
Queen takes D4 you think to yourself ah
this bishop is hanging I'm gonna go over
here go Queen check and aren't I so
clever I'm going to grab this bishop and
then when you're about to reach for and
take this bishop take my rock oh no this
didn't make into this didn't make it
into take my rock Yer because you'd have
to take two in this case you only take
one and you end up with a Checkmate yeah
that's like that's not just taking a
rook that's made in three right exactly
so against this bishop B4 check uh
leavon had to move his King which is
considered um obviously a loss of the
opportunity to the castle and with this
move he's
inviting um uh Fabian to play the move
Bishop C3 and to try to snap this Pawn
off the board after Bishop C3 however
Rook B1 white gets a pretty nice attack
going over here on the queen side as
well as trying to keep Black's King in
the center so always a nice thing to do
keep that King in the center and those
two shabo doing work
two what two shabo two shabo that
Philadelphia speak I think that's what
Greg and I used to call them shabo and
it's stuck it's stuck with us apparently
not anybody else though for me it was
the 2bs 2bs Maurice uh what do you think
about the openings and how they're
shaping up today are you
surprised I'm quite surprised and I'm
learning quite a bit about these
variations seeing some offbeat lines
take place on the board and some stuff I
just frankly I've never seen before this
line most popularly in this variation
the game that we are now following
between kowana and aonian aronian with
the white pieces here aronian played
castles in a game just this year in
Dubai a rapid game against ryabov in
that game they ended up in a draw but in
this game he decided to play a second
most the second most popular move by a
long way by the way most popular move
castles 1465 games in the database this
move only 390 games in the database and
here after D4 again we see they're
popular lines to play but we've
consistently seen the players go below
the radar try to find some Wrinkle in
the Lesser lines instead of Bishop E7
which is the most popular response
second most popular is C takes D4 and
now they follow pretty much standard
moves in the next couple of moves and in
this position after Knight takes Queen
takes by a long way 97 games in the
database with Queen takes on D4 only
nine with C3 takes D4 this move
certainly not at all considered critical
and main reason why this move Bishop to
B4 check the latest game top game
between Anish giri the young Phenom and
vishwanathan Anan former world champion
and in this position Bishop D2 was not
tried King F1 is considered the critical
way to play if white wants to play for
something special instead of trading off
more pieces this move uh King over and a
new move on the board now caruana
playing Bishop to D6 this has never been
tried castles was the main move here uh
instead of Bishop to D6 so here we have
a novelty on the board at least from our
databases and aonian having seen it now
for the first time recognizing yes
that's a novelty and he's got to think
about why would you play this move in
this position just dropping the bishop
back from any dangers with Queen A4 but
of course castles was possible so an
intriguing moment in the game not sure
why this move was played we have to
study it some more to understand the
nuances guys Maurice thank you for that
uh really quite a remarkable uh game
going on here uh what I was thinking
that uh leavon was trying to do was that
in case um Fabiana had played the
natural castles I saw an opportunity to
snap a pawn here by playing Rook B1 with
a direct attack against the bishop if
the Bishop drops back to D6 I could grab
this Pawn you know me I'm a pawn grubber
and uh black would have a compensation
no question but would it be um enough
for a pawn this bishop is is putting a
lot of pressure on White's King but
white has F3 with the idea of developing
his forces I know you like your Pawn I
like my Pawn you give it away in the way
you ask the question exactly is it worth
a pawn you got to ask but here's the
wild move Bishop okay instead of castles
Bishop D6 as Maurice was saying the
novelty white needs to solve what's he
going to do with his Rook right then I
think everybody's natural move would be
to play Rook B1 and put pressure so that
when you do move this bishop you could
put your king tuck your king away
instead this hearkens back to the days
when I was a beginner and I would start
with my opening move H2
H4 check this move out H2 H4 by leavon
and the idea here is he's thinking about
developing his his Rook with a ro with a
Rover for example if we see the move
castles
H5 if we see H6 I believe his idea is
that he wants to bring his Rook to H4
either to G4 or to E4 anticipating that
one day this move E7 E5 is going to be
very creative very creative I mean we
did see some weird h4s in this
tournament like even the very
controversial H4 by Fabiano in that game
where he was attacking Magnus Caron our
world champion H4 instead of castling
which is second would have liked to have
seen it's it's interesting how some of
our my phrases catch on like Rover Rook
up and over and some like the two shaboo
just we can't make it happen stop trying
to make that happen shoos I that'll I
it's not it's not going to happen I need
to get used to that one I must confess
the Rover the Rover I like you that that
that's high marks also one other
possible use of the move H4 is that you
might be able to play Bishop G5 uh in
order to develop with a Tempo I don't
think that's quite as critical but I
like this Rover idea or maybe if the
Rover doesn't work out you have your
potential Castle kingside the laid
Castle in King side you mean the old
Castles by hand King G1 King H2 type of
deal allowing Queen takes H4 check oops
all right uh in our big fight for second
place the the the game that will
determine the second place winner in
this event $225,000 difference between
second and third vessel and top pull off
in a must-win situation Magnus can
clinch second with a draw after the move
Bishop B4 we saw Knight E2 and as
expected
the sneaky move Bishop A6 attacking The
Rook The Rook had to go to a less than
fortunate Square Rook F1 to C1 and
Magnus has played Bishop to E2 insisting
on the one hand he wanted to uh try to
double White's pawns on the queen side
now with this move Bishop E2 his intent
quite clearly is to double White's pawns
on the king side now speaking of the
Berlin Joseph Levine tweets that I
suspect it takes more than one night to
learn the berlan indeed not easy I would
say more than one month but uh for those
dedicated uh I'm sure you'll you'll get
a lot out of it you you will learn a lot
take it on a few dates not just one not
on that's this one so Knight on F3 to D2
a very different Berlin than we're used
to seeing usually black uh tries to play
very solid gets compact uh position and
only much later uh he reaches out for
active play we've seen Magnus come out
very powerfully and playing extreme
active moves that you don't see in a
Berlin I'm sure if you went through the
last 2,000 games uh you'd be very hard
pressed to find a black Bishop on the E2
Square after a m 14 moves Maurice am I
right on that one is that a rarity or
what relatively rare but guess who's
been on the black side of this position
twice Vladimir kramnik himself Mr Berlin
who used this opening to good effect
against former world champion and Legend
who will be later on our show uh Gary
Kasparov he did not use this particular
wrinkle against C against Gary but he
has played it against some Heavy Hitters
he played this against kakin uh one of
the top 10 players in the world and
Alexis shirov also a great genius in
chess and he had a great record with it
as well did kak did uh crnic excuse me
cnck used this one draw and one win
although uh one of the games was indeed
a Blitz game the idea behind this line
after the bishop moved trying to double
pawns on this side now this bishop A6
and Rook F to C1 was necessary here the
main reason being that if you played The
Rook over to D1 then you'd run into that
Bishop to E2 move disrupting the the pin
the uh position here The Rook now has to
go somewhere and then Bishop takes
Knight and then you get doubled on the
other side so Rook fc1 was played and
now Bishop E2 and the popular move here
is Knight to to H2 bringing the Knight
over on this side of the board six games
played in this line but Knight to D2
Knight
fd2 is another move very infrequently
played not played by the top players
certainly not played by kakin or shirov
this move meant to bring the Knight to
this side to the board and now the
engines are saying that although this is
not an often played line that the
position is slightly better for white so
Knight
fd2 has topar prepared this whole line
knowing that this move gives him a
little bit more than the other move this
move by the way allows him to bring his
Rook to E1 without having to worry about
this bishop so already white is planning
to move this Bish this bishop off this
Square I want to show you a key
difference here if you play Knight to H2
black has various moves here Rook d8
being a very popular one now you cannot
bring the Rook over to attack this
bishop until you play the move C3 now
once you play C3 you've weakened some
squares so let's say the bishop drops
back now when you attack this piece this
bishop has options it could go either to
D3 or it could go to C4 it has these two
choices in this position but if we go
back now to this moment and you put in
insert this move when whatever move you
play now when your Bishop is attacked
you no longer have either this move or
this move you have to gravel all the way
back to the A6 square and you wonder
Well why'd you put your Bishop there in
the first place because now C3 will come
chasing your Bishop back and this bishop
is back on A6 having made two moves for
absolutely no reason so Knight fd2 is in
an important wrinkle here that Carlson
overlooked we'll see as the game unfolds
in a battle for second place here in the
last round of the singfield cup guys
thank you Maurice and and just that last
final position that you showed in your
analysis got to keep in mind that in
many times in the Berlin white is very
happy to play the move E5 E6 trading
this Pawn on E5 that often times gets in
the way of this bishop for this double
Pawn on C7 and if after for example in
this position uh let's say this move
Rook d8 what Maurice was showing as well
as Rook E1 you can toss an E6 and this
is something that black has to be very
wary of because again his King is still
in the center so at the moment I'm going
to say um topof uh for choice in this
battle in the
opening well speaking of surprises today
we have Gary Kasparov former world
champion human rights activist author
speaker coming on later and we also have
one of the funniest Grand Masters out
there Ben F benold humanitarian author
speaker and and a funny dude birthday
boy that's right happy birthday to Ben
fold I would sing it but I think
everybody would turn off the broadcast
so I'll turn it over to Maurice's lovely
vocals funny looking her funny Maurice
take it away thanks Jen I'm not going to
sing either but happy birthday Ben thank
you thank you so I even got my present
with you got your present W very
exciting it's all wrapped in a nice bow
uh so your birthday gift round 10 of the
singfield cup that's a pretty cool gift
that's a good gift yeah uh but they put
you to work anyway today didn't they
that's what happens you catch no breaks
well let's get to the games man this
game here between Carlson and topalov
this new move night F to D2 instead of
Knight H2 well not totally new has been
played at the lower levels but this
seems like an improvement over Knight h
to giving this rookie one a chance to
just chase that bishop and make it look
irrelevant on the A6 Square having made
those two moves what are your thoughts
about this right I actually like this
move and um well Magnus just played I
guess the this is the the actual game he
played Bishop he did Play Bishop takes I
think you have to do that I think if
white gets C3 and then Black's a little
too cramped with his Bishop on E7 um
yeah actually karnick had two nice wins
with black against two really strong
players after net H2 this line scores
really well for black B6 not being as
popular and well topoff plays the Black
side of the Berlin as we saw when he
beat Nakamura so he probably knows the
B6 line and this is probably what he had
ready for it was Knight fd2 Alejandra
said something interesting in our joint
commentary he says white can't really
lose this position but as we pointed out
white has to win this game um not only
does he get more prize money he'll be
third in the world if he wins this game
he'll go up in the world rankings so I
think topof wants to win pretty pretty
incredible considering that he lost the
first two games of the competition and
was losing in round three so quite a
shock to see him him come back of course
Magnus is looking to cement himself as
well he hasn't had a m a less than plus
two performance for 20 consecutive
tournaments so he's got to try to win
also just to just to keep his streak
alive no I think both players want to
win this game and of course it's a major
success for topov if he not only comes
in clear second third in the world and a
big after losing the first two would be
amazing so this would be incredible if
top love wins if Magnus wins I think he
only loses two rating points this
tournament so that's okay not the worst
tournament ever
absolutely now we go to a game between
aonian and Carana and this is bizarre I
mean you don't often see a king sitting
on F1 in the opening Pawn in H5 open
Play what does white really have here
for this formation right and actually
this was a noname a noname this year
last year but it was uh like a rapid
blindfold game it wasn't yeah it wasn't
black wasn't the most important game of
the year right um no I think if if white
wants to get an advantage he has to play
King F1 here actually Queen takes D4 is
more more normal than C takes and okay
aonian is trying to get a position
that's a little bit unusual and I think
he really wants to win today he hasn't
won since round two and I think uh he'd
like to finish the ter on a high note I
don't think the king is badly placed on
F1 I think it's going to go to G2 later
white has a little better Center I think
we actually preferred white a little bit
here but yeah a little little bit
unusual play that pawn on H5 doesn't
concern you well it concerns me actually
for both players the end game it could
become weak but uh if leavon gets an
attack going it might concern
Fabiano indeed so let's go to this
position between Nakamura and Maxim
vashi lrav and this one is probably the
most dynamic of all the positions all
the minor pieces still on the board well
at least one trade of minors are the
knights but this just looks like an
exotic Sicilian the kind of thing we
love to see being battled at the high
level yeah and we and these are both
nidorf players we thought maybe we'd see
a n when mvl was white as well but it
didn't happen um nakam MZ actually
played this line with black um as I
suspected and he played a little bit
differently this was a game played by
Webster student lequang liim who's
actually playing chess right now um so
he can't be here to help us out uh he
had a draw with Mark paragua in the
Asian Continental last year and let's
see they made a move since I came over I
think this is still the game so that
game was a 29 move draw and we thought
black more or less equalized it sort of
looks like a fesov except black maybe a
Tempo or two ahead of normal positions
and the bishop on H6 is pretty good we
didn't have to you know go to G5 and E7
and move the bishop around so yeah maybe
about equal but a dynamic kind of equal
we're going to expect a decisive result
so big fight still for the bottom of the
tournament table were you shocked
yesterday that Carana missed this win
and Rook takes G6 that was one of the
most shocking I mean he had several wins
that he missed but Rook take G6 I mean I
found it so I was really surprised that
Fabiano didn't find it and he just said
like he wasn't looking for it that
wasn't and yeah I read on the you know I
saw you guys that like right away hakaru
told him after the game hey you could
have beaten me with Rook take G6 yeah
that dig that seems like something aara
would just play in a one minute game
without thinking um both games I was
surprised he didn't win I thought he was
going to win against Carlson I thought
fiveon was going to win yesterday but
okay the breaks have been put on a
little bit he's already won the
tournament I'm sure he still wants to
win today cuz n out of 10 ain't bad
indeed is not bad at all well thanks Ben
again for your insights and uh get some
cake I'll see what I can
do Grandmaster Ben fine gold back to you
guys and we do have a little birthday
wish for Grandmaster Ben fold happy
birthday and uh it's a happy birthday
puzzle actually it's a happy birthday
we'll show you what Ben did
here Queen takes
G2 Ben nice move King takes G2 oh when
it went away we lost graphic that was
against Michael Cella California dude
who also plays a ton of Poker Dre well I
was gonna ask Ben about his
Recollections of the game but was it a
good pick I like that game it was a good
pick he said he liked it it was a winner
it was a winner it was a queen sack yeah
nice one got to love a queen sack
birthday Queen sacrifice very nice well
very good uh I just got this game
between Hikaru and Maxine on my screen
green and I'm thinking from White's
point of view Jen if white needs to do
something uh to uh break open the game
and I keep coming back to this move F2
F4 I don't know if it's the best or what
or brightest idea but at least it's a
very crisp idea of playing F4 F5 we
could see a lot of Trades going on a
Kind of a Funny recapture pardon me well
actually we do have some more moves in
the game and Nakamura avoided having to
recapture with a pawn by chopping his
Knight back to E2 and this game's
actually still following that paragua
Quang Liam kuang game that we mentioned
earlier that ended in the 29 move draw
so knight2 challenging the Knight on D4
and what hikaro wants to see is that in
case of a tradeit of knights what he's
going to try to do if you get a Bishop's
of opposite color position for argument
sake is to try to prove that this bishop
on a six although it covers an open
diagonal for the moment is rather
ineffective and white will want to
pressure this Pawn on D6 if on the other
hand it's probably a better idea for
black to actually uh Swap this bishop
and indeed that's what happened and now
Nakamura is showing the point of his
another point of his Knight maneuver is
that now he can take back with the queen
and put some pressure on B7 and also
keep that uh pristine Pond structure um
and now we pawns yeah we have the First
new move B5 aha previous the the the
players have followed this exact that
that same uh paragua um Liam Quang game
right which you had mentioned and
instead of B5 the previous moveie that
had been played was drum roll Rook B8
youve got a def King G7 with the idea of
just Queen takes B7 Rook there Rook
takes C2 huh I see yeah okay so B7 B5 on
the board uh
and we discussed earlier how that can
become a potential Target not to mention
that after A4 for example so you try to
uh weaken up um bust up the queen site
structure a bit for example if you take
take now you're a little bit happier
because these pawns are nice and this
Pond is still a Target well I wonder if
um he'll use the same idea behind uh uh
paragua uh King D7 with the idea that
after B5 A4 is B5 really inake I'm I
know I'm just saying that same kind of
spirit that because C2 is pressured
after B5 A4 so we really have to do
something immediately about that or can
we right so for example a for King
G7 perhap there's a better move but
right point being that that the queen
takes B5 Rook takes C2 letting my Rook
get so active I'm not sure that's a
great idea no but okay because this Pawn
on B5 sticks out a little bit like a
sore thumb I think this move Knight E2
to C3 we're seeing the Knight going back
and forth a lot but it accomplishes
something with each uh turn that it
steps on the E2 Square now stepping on
the C3 Square means that this Pawn on B5
has been isolated and is now targeted in
two ways so I'm thinking well I'm a pond
grubber my favorite living condition
being a pawn ahead this would be a good
line for Caro yeah B5 does leave an
interesting impression although it seems
like preparation problem is I'd like to
play something like Queen a I would like
to play after B5 A4 it would be nice to
play a move maybe like Queen A5 but I'm
leaving night7 hanging that's why it's
important to kind of preface all this
with the move uh King G7 just not to uh
well the move Knight E7 check at the end
of the day I'll still have my queen on
pre so Queen on A5 Queen A5 is
certainly uh possible it's a candidate
but it needs to be very carefully
analyzed well exact L because you've
always got to keep in mind that Knight
E7 check or or even Knight F6 and Rook
takes D6 can happen in some situations
so sure so uh some difficulties still
for Maxine at the moment let's return to
our Champions uh game Fabiana Karana
okay we have seen this move H4 H5 uh
also we're just going to go back a step
so I can show I like this move very much
this move Rook B8 by Fabiano by the way
I wanted to comment on it as Fabiano has
a very clear idea in mind he wants to
fianchetto his bishop and this bishop on
G2 is a very effective piece so the
trade of that passive Bishop on C8 for
the bishop on G2 which strategically
speaking uh be in Black's favor so I
like that move H5 trying to get in
H6 and weaken the dark squares around
Black's King H6 was played and now white
to play
so leavon has to decide what he wants to
do can he essay this Rook lift hoping
for Rook G4 or to bring that rook in the
center or does he have a more mundane
idea in mind something like Bishop F3
and King G2 lastly if I was in white
shoes I would like to play a move like
Queen D3 here just developing my queen
keeping an eye over all sectors of the
board and preparing for a possible even
Bishop F4 so very rich strategical
position going on here uh between the
fight between the world's number two and
number three players indeed a
fascinating struggle Maurice what
intrigues you about today's round the
most which game do you have your eyes
peeled
on well no question about it is the
Nakamura game that one has all those
interesting pieces still on the board
lots of fight to play for and the
interesting pieces I'm referring to of
the knights and if we take a look at
this game between aonian and Carana we
see that the knights have left the board
now the knights really they're the spice
of chess chess would be in my opinion a
much duller game without the knights
they're the one piece that of course do
not move in linear fashion secondly if
they attack another piece that piece is
definitely not attacking them back that
is if it's not a KN of course and if
they are attacked then they can't be
attacking that other the piece back as
well so they create the tension other
linear pieces if if a bishop attacks a
queen and then you see that those those
two things are squaring off against each
other and the same thing with a rook and
a queen linear pieces tend to be very
direct very obvious and they simply need
open lines to come alive Knights don't
this position you see that the knights
are off and when I look at this I feel
like white doesn't have much potential
here to create a big attack because the
pieces are too straightforward it's not
easy at all for him to find unique
squares for his pieces where they're
going to dominate maybe if his Bishop
could end up on C2 like you said YZ and
put a queen on D3 that could be an
interesting idea this maneuver of course
B6 and Bishop B7 is coming quickly to
counter his Bishop that's the problem
with linear pieces easy to counter along
lines unless you find dominant diagonals
for them this bishop is also searching
for a square to go to B2 is not a bad
Square it looks like but that blocks
this linear Rook on B1 and again the
pawn on B6 is going to be a Factor so
black has a very clear plan in this
position and he's looking to implement
B6 Bishop to B7 try to trade more pieces
and then get his Rooks to the open files
meantime this king is not so secure on
the F1 Square so that could be a problem
for him I jump to this game right here
between topalov and Carana now this
position just to go back a couple of
moves here Carana played Knight D4 this
is still in this Theory that's not so
popular Theory not the big grandm games
but lower down on the rating scale but
apparently this position is only maybe a
smidgen better for white but when you
look at it carefully you start to feel
like is it really anything for white
however white does have a plan here and
topalov played forward he played the
move Bishop to E3 now this move
unfortunately if the Knight were to
leave he could play for F4 and get that
plan going so Magnus has to fight very
seriously against this plan of f4
because now that he no longer has the
two Bishops and his Pawn structure here
is compromised it's four never makes a
pass Pawn against this three he can't
let topalov just play F4 and everything
if he gets everything then it's all
white so in this position the move
Knight to F5 has been played now here of
course you don't want to just give up
this bishop uh this this bishop for that
night and Fracture the pawn structure so
most likely in my opinion you're going
to see this move get played and after
that he could play Knight to D4 will we
see the first strange repetition of the
tournament the players have a a clause
in their contract that they must not
play less than 30 moves unless forced to
do so unless absolutely forced to do so
so now in order to avoid that topalov
and he has played Bishop to F4 and if
car plays Knight back to
D4 which he has done we may see this
Clause come into effect does velin have
to come up with a different move in this
position he has to move C3 as well so he
could keep playing this position out but
if he plays Bishop to E3 there's going
to be some controversy here because he's
certainly not forced to play the move
and he's not worse after C3 so Bishop E3
repeats moves C3 keeps the game going
we'll follow this now this strange
development as it unfolds guys thank you
Maurice well not that I'm a betting
woman or anything but I'm betting
against the the draw by R I don't
believe it's going to happen well again
from Vin's point of view so much uh at
stake that he's giving I if he were to
GRE to such a short repetition he's he's
seeding uh the world champion um the
second place and again as mention
remarkably I didn't realize that that uh
because leavon ronian is having such a
poor result if topof could actually uh
Garner or win here he he jumps to number
three in the world that's very very
meaningful
so
I'm C2 C2 C3 uh keeping the game alive
playing for the result is what he should
play guys but isn't it illegal for him
to play Bishop E3 no allowed to I mean
the reality is Bishop e he does not have
to play Bishop E3 C3 is a normal game so
he cannot go to the Arbiter and say I
have proof I must play Bishop E3 or some
worse no no no but a but but a normal
three-fold repetition or a Perpetual
check if you'd like uh that's perfectly
E3 perfectly legit perfectly legit but
you can do it one more time without of
being a w right or not really because
after Knight F5 then would that be um
would that be four that it was still
only B2 so he can still do Knight F5
Bishop F4 and change his mind at that
moment gain time for later one of the
issues is that um Arbiter International
Arbiter Chris bird is a strong chess
player but I think we're seeing a draw
by the way Chen sorry didn't claim it I
before playing Knight D4 wow very
surprising to me indeed awful result I
really think that's quite
surprising yeah especially because uh
and we are calling uh for the
international arbit to Crest bird the
problem the logistical problem here is
that unless your International Arbiter
was a grandmas now Chris is not a bad
player but he's obviously not a top 10
player in the world it would be very
difficult to prevent something like this
without creating errors in other cases
so that's a little bit of a lis IAL
difficulty normally it's not an issue
because these players are so combative
especially the ones that we invited to
the singfield cup sure that it just
wouldn't be necessary they would always
play the most exciting lines anyway and
it is a draw um Magnus Carlson and veln
topov um vesselin after really
impressing Us in the second half with a
very strange decision in the last round
I think to uh take a repetition instead
of presses white agreed um something in
the opening threw him off this Knight D2
whether he underestimated Bishop takes
D2 I'm really not too sure what happened
um Magnus is laughing meanwhile you know
always with a sense of humor he's he's
giggling it'll be interesting to to hear
his thoughts on this decision oh
definitely um but again this result by
the way does secure for Magnus the
second place so congratulations the
world champion for having taken second
however it also means that overall the
event has seen a loss of Elo rating
points I think um Magnus loses something
like five or six uh ELO points from this
result so right and the streak to be
number one and the streak is over so
this is the first time in 20 tournaments
that Magnus has not achieved a score of
plus two or higher I don't think Magnus
would be too happy about this I think if
he knew that Vaseline might do this that
he would have actually um perhaps played
a different line of the Roy Lopez of
course he has other weapons at his
disposal of what do you think like maybe
remember he played Just G6 against Naka
but he could play all sorts of things
well as we saw even the accelerated
dragon and so forth and so on
um I saw something yesterday which is so
unusual for me uh I just don't see it in
Magnus at all he was gen genuinely
distressed yesterday it wasn't just a a
I was really surprised by it because not
just disappointment it was like
exasperation bordering on what's going
what's wrong he was horrified and it was
really kind of um in a way it was
impressive to me because I thought that
that end game was really deep and
instructive and he was just like I can't
believe I missed it I'm the worst simple
I me of course like compared to what
Fabiano missed it was way way more
difficult even the engines the engines
had no clue what was going on and
actually Grandmaster Pavo alov um
tweeted that he was really impressed by
the endgame play there to the by both
players um in that they created so many
Rich possibilities and instruction for
us Maurice I know you're not happy about
this result give us your thoughts on
kind of what what a little bit of a a
bitter taste and what has been one of
the most combative tournaments in
history absolutely Jen this kind of
result the fans hate uh you paid money
to come down to lesters to watch a
heavyweight battle and you saw this you
you just walk out and disgust so I think
that it's unfortunate that this happened
in the last round of the tournament
clearly the players know that there's
not much to play for by way of first but
there was so much to play for by way of
second place and the the whole
tournament has been a magnificent treat
of Fighting Chess Gladiators battling to
the end this is in fact the first game
that ended in a quick draw in the entire
tournament and ended under 20 moves so
that certainly leaves a real bad taste
in the mount to see this finish I'm sure
Carlson will have his opinions about why
it is that he had to do this or why this
happened of course he had the black
pieces usually the player with the black
pieces doesn't have much choice toala
will have to defend himself with the
white pieces getting nothing at all and
then is Che the line C3 which continued
the game I mean that could have that
seems like it could have gone somewhat
more after the move C3 certainly he
might say look even after that I have
nothing or maybe even in his opinion
he's worse but it's a to me a very sad
finish to this tournament by these two
great great players fan favorites great
Fighters but not showing their best in
this last game well we are going to get
the players set up for interviews
Maurice and while we have vesselin topof
who's going to enter the studio we're
going to go out and have a chat with
Taran play people have been coming in
all across the country in fact some of
them inspired to come without previous
plans and she talks from one such man
from Dallas
hi Jen yes thank you I am here with Dr
laan and he came from Houston after
watching our broadcast last week you
said I've got to be here in St Louis and
it's your first time here what are your
impressions of the chess
club very very very nice chess club and
I would like to compliment the sin
fields for the superb organization of
this world class tournament uh all the
games so far has been very exciting and
uh I wish to be back here next year
hopefully as a participant oh I'm just
kidding I like to hear that you you know
speaking of which have you played some
world class chess players by chance yes
uh in 1990 in New York City I played in
a simultaneous uh game against anatol
carpo in New York City but I was playing
actually against two opponents uh Mr
carpov and my wife uh this was her
second trip to New York City and she was
rushing me up she wanted to go shopping
while I'm trying to fight for my life
against Mr carpov in fact I have a a
photograph of our
game this was in
1990 and two months after that he played
his last title match against Kasparov so
he he was still in the top of the
mountain then and my knowledge of chess
can be contained in the back of a
postage stamp I don't play chess very
well but you've had some wonderful
memories and making memories here now I
I would say I don't regret coming here
and most probably I'll be back next year
that's great to hear and what has been
the most exciting part of the chess this
whole tournament for you I think meeting
the chess players in person I meet all
six of them yes and uh and to watch them
actually play instead of just on
television that's something else uh the
last time I was able to do that was when
Bobby Fisher went to Manila in 1967
there was a tournament there called bit
Bobby Fisher and he played against my
cousin um Joseph Pascal who was at the
time the national champion wow wow so
you have some wonderful chess memories
to share with us thank you for doing so
and thank you for coming to St Louis I'm
so glad I love the city okay well thank
you we expect to see you back next year
as the participant yes thank you well
we'll go down to you Jen thank you thank
you Taran lovely lovely interview you'd
always like to see the field mixed up
indeed and we do have vesselin topav to
talk to Grandmas Maurice Ashley about
our shortest game of the sinkfield cup
so
far thanks Jen I am with veline topala
former world champion worldcast player
veline first of all congratulations on
your finish we know you started with a
rough tournament you're losing your
first two games you bounced back
tremendously to have a Fine Results
however we're a bit surprised by this
game it was a combative game or at least
an opportunity to have a combative game
to go for second place in the tournament
Le frogging uh Magnus Carlson with the
white pieces it was a quick draw the
shortest draw of the tournament why is
that that you made this decision no it's
uh simply obviously that you know the
opening Choice okay so for for some
reason
I decided to go for uh the Queens the
for E4 at the beginning you know and
it's one of the openings that we
expected and I think Magnus chose a good
strategy you know to immediately go for
exchanging the queens and some solid uh
lines but there are too many different
sublines you know so exactly what he
played in the opening somehow I couldn't
really remember I could somehow and
immediately we reach this position you
know which I think I have a choice
between continue the game but I I I it's
very uh you know uh neat because uh I I
think if I just don't go for this
repetition then I'm afraid what could
really become worse do you think C3 is
not a good option here no honestly I
don't like it because then uh simply the
Knight goes to E6 and there's a very
important Square for the bishop and it's
about all about trying to you know to
somehow use the uh the misplacement of
the bishop on to and with with the move
C3 I don't like it somehow because the
bishop goes to to D3 and then the pawn
is Advanced to H5 or maybe H4 and then
uh my my pawns would uh would have been
stopped and I think then uh black would
have even an easier game so you believe
that black would have actually
maintained an advantage potentially
after a move C3 well maybe not really an
advantage but I think honestly I would
prefer black to to play with you know uh
after the after the move C3 I my opinion
is computer is wrong you know uh are you
disappointed that this became the result
of this game not getting second place or
a chance to fight for second a little
bit because you know the idea was of
course at least I with white you should
at least try to win you know and somehow
I let the draw very too easily but okay
it's also true that uh I was mostly
counting uh on some other openings you
know because so far in this event Magnus
he never really played this the Berling
defense which is maybe the most solid
opening now days against the you know
the against E4 E4 and uh but okay it was
also the same well it was expected this
is what he did in the world championship
match and that's by far the most solid
opening and the
hardest uh crack to you know uh to break
with his big streak he has gone 20
tournaments in in a row and maintain
plus two now he has only a plus one
result which is sort of one of the worst
performance we can't really call the
worst because this event is so strong
are you surprised that he decided to
play Only solidly In the last round
instead of really looking for a big
result well I don't think he really
cares between plus one or two because
it's uh you know it's about first place
or second and well since he already lost
his chances to play for the first then
he could only secure the second and
watch
which he it uh but well I don't think
honestly that he cares and he even knows
that he made all this 20 tournaments in
a row with plus two result which is
really actually he was the one who told
us so so yeah he he does know uh well
probably he he has all these records
that uh you know uh he keeps in mind but
uh again it's really not only that he
played well and he won the world
championship titles but he was not only
he was not really really losing many
games and he was never down in the
tournament so it's it's normal just two
more questions for you first of all with
your minus two start you came back in
the tournament what lessons will you
take away from your play here at this
the strongest tournament
ever well I mean um basically I think I
will I will just plus two against the
regular guys and I lost two games to
Fabiano which shouldn't count really so
I'm almost say shouldn't count okay come
on he lost everything he won everything
here so it's not really I mean that's
the you know sometimes it happens that
all your opponents jumped to your
preparation and that was a bit you know
what happened not only he played well
but he was a little bit lucky with the
openings because especially with the
white pieces almost in all games uh even
the the the games he drew you know uh he
was getting close to Big advantages or
close to winning positions if people
were calling this luck he drew two games
uh with white that he to All rights he
should have won I mean in some ways he's
unlucky in those two games and then he's
plus seven after all and he won a lot of
those games with black as well no
actually most of his games he won was
with black actually it's true that uh he
was plus seven without luck actually and
it's very change honestly because but I
again carp 20 years ago when he made all
this big result this big result in
linaris
1994 that was same case that uh he won
plus a lot you know and then he could
even he was pressing several more games
he missed I think he was better against
kamsky Kasparov and shirov a great
memory for 20 years ago finally give you
an opportunity to talk about the
singfield Cup itself the the organizers
your feelings about being able to play
here in St Louis I mean okay it was
really for me a great opportunity
because somehow you know the Chess World
we always going to the same places for
me that's a new place and okay not new
faces because all these guys I've I've
played before but it's certainly good to
open new markets and uh especially
America it's a very important country
for chess and I don't think F really
does great job here so thanks to Rex you
know I think chess is still alive you
know and really I believe F should do a
lot more for for chess in in the states
well we appreciate that sentiment and
the States loves your style of Play We
wish you the best in your future
tournaments and look forward to seeing
you back here in the states at the
future singfield cups with great
pleasure thanks so much Vil too one of
the great players in the history of
Chess we wish him well guys a fantastic
competitor coming back from two losses
at the start in the world's strongest
tournament ever boy you know that is
really a remarkable achievement now we
have a very star studded uh 15 minutes
of chass because not only do we have
world champion Magnus Carlson getting
set up for an interview but soon after
that we're going to hear from Gary
Casper so all right entertain me let's
go and here he is world champion Magnus
Carlson is with grand for marce Ashley
Thanks Jen I am with the world number
one player Magnus Carlson Magnus first
of all congratulations on your second
place finish sure you don't you seem a
bit muted in that uh that feeling about
coming in second place before we get to
that uh this position here were you
pleased to be able to play well you
played to Berlin so you forced a sort of
solid position we were surprised that
you would go for what seemed like an
ultra solid position to play the last
game your streak of 20 tournaments or
more with with at least a plus well 20
tournaments with at least a plus two
score or more has been broken now you're
only a plus one what are your feelings
about
that uh I don't know um was not so happy
about the game yesterday I was a little
bit tired uh a little bit tense I
couldn't sleep so well and I got
um a massage today before the round I
hoped it would make me feel better but
it just knocked me out
so um no I I I wanted to play
um I wanted to play really solidly today
um because I was not feeling so great
and obviously he a strong
player it's very hard to beat him with
black um and uh I thought if he uh I
mean if he tries to play I will I will
play but as it turned out he kind of
misplayed it a little bit in the opening
and um and uh I think the position we
have on the board he probably should
take the draw by repetition because
otherwise he might be might might be
slightly worse uh although computer
doesn't say so but computer doesn't
understand everything about the BR in
defense so you feel that it was a
legitimate draw a good time to stop were
you surprised that he played this
solidly and then try something maybe a
bit more interesting against the Berlin
to keep the game alive and fighting CH I
think I think he um mixed up something
in the opening because the way the I
mean the point really of uh of my play
here is this maneuver like this when I
get uh a very easy game here I could
also play Rook d8 immediately but uh or
maybe that's not so great but when I get
this position generally when I get to
exchang the dark squared Bishop um for
uh for one of his Knights um and
activate my Bishop then I'm always
always okay and um in this position in
Natural Choice for him would be to kick
my knight with C3 yes okay and then I
would ah sometime trust me I've suffered
with it too throughout and then Bishop
to
E3 I would play
H5 and let's say
F4
uh Bishop
D3 and uh well my feeling was that white
could just as easily uh get slightly
worse here so I can very much understand
that he just took the draw okay
interesting insights the computer still
saying a slight Edge but you mentioned
this are difficult positions for the
engines to really understand the second
place in the tournament is not what you
go for when you play in a chess
tournament you always are looking for
first what are your feelings about
coming in second of course Fabiano had a
fantastic result no I mean coming in
second when when guy scores uh well at
least eight points out of 10 uh is is
obviously okay
um for me it's more about my own
performance uh rather than uh result uh
I
think my my performance hasn't been that
great um there there has there have been
some good moments but there have been
too many mediocre ones uh as well and
um I I got a good start with H with two
good draws with black uh then my two
next games with white was uh was a
disaster I could have lost both um I
think I recovered pretty well after that
two wins no losses but even here in the
second half
um I had serious chances against lra and
winning position against Aran obviously
I could have lost to to Carana but
nevertheless
um it's it's really um yeah too many bad
moments and if if I'd been second and
scored six or six and a half points then
that would would have been all right uh
six points is nce I mean five and a half
uh that's
uh too little to be to be satisfied but
it's it's not a disaster so you came
into this tournament uh by far number
one in the world now Fabiano has closed
the Gap somewhat do you feel like this
tournament indicates a real change in
terms of Fabiano being your main
Contender number two in the world
solidly or is it just that he had the
spectacular results and we still need to
see some more from him to prove himself
I it's it's hard to uh to say um in in
zui this this year um leavon had a live
rating of uh thir
2835 and he was playing wonderful chess
just one the vikon
brilliantly um and uh then it was clear
for everyone that he was he was the main
Challenger so um so I guess I guess uh
it's it's early to say um
but
um but of course um if he can keep um
something close to this level up then um
then it's going to be tough um but uh
once again yeah it's one tournament and
shouldn't draw too many conclusions
which what do you think about
yesterday's game this Rook takes Knight
Miss Rook takes G6 yeah it's with
I he's clearly clearly tired as are
other people um since
um that's um that's something a good
player on form should find every
time
but I guess
um yeah I mean technically could have
had nine from nine which would have been
completely ridiculous we couldn't even
calculate his performance ready if he
had done that last question for you uh
the singfield cup has been good to you
at least last year was very good to you
you came in second this year what do you
think about the organization the
tournament itself as a staple on the
tournament circuit know everything's
been been great um uh discussed ideas
with Rex already for for the next one
and hope to be back
so very happy that uh um Rex and the St
Louis chess club is doing such a great
job for chess and it's
um yeah it's a great new addition to the
to the tournament circuit so um I'm I'm
just hoping next time maybe uh it will
be a two horse race instead of uh just
one well thank you so much we're happy
to hear that you enjoy this tournament
and we wish you the best in your future
events thank you world champion Magnus
Carson a bit muted about second place
but good news for us he'll be back guys
smiling so much my face is starting to
hurt cuz we love to hear that he wants
to come back world champion Magnus
Carlson good news and from one hero to
another chess hero we are going to take
a quick break and then we will be back
with Gary
[Music]
COV
my name is Fabiano Carana and you are
watching the Sinker field Cup live in St
Louis and welcome back to round 10 cover
of the singfield cup the strongest
Tournament of all time and we have a
treat for you it is always a pleasure to
welcome the former world champion one of
the legendary players of Chess Gary
Kasparov himself to the show Gary
welcome thanks for joining us thanks for
inviting me Gary like all of us you must
be watching uh with wonderment at the
performance of this young man Fabiano
Carana you've seen it all in chess what
did you think about how he played in
this tournament
it's an amazing tournament um we may
recall few other events uh with similar
results I think carpo had eight out of
nine uh in linaris I have I had a streak
of seven victories in thean but first of
all this to is much stronger than those
that I mentioned and also what is most
amazing that uh he had uh such a
phenomenal result without any luck I
mean I can easily recall few Gam that
carpo was lucky in in in lares I
probably was lucky in couple of games
with Vian but um car actually could have
even even even a bigger score because
two two draws he made uh it was him
missing winning chances did you feel
like that he was tired at the end
missing those moves Rook T G6 certainly
was bad I think I think it's tired he's
tired and actually I I'm surprised that
he could play with such energy for so
long I remember my own own you know um
uh feelings in v i I made a draw in the
first round then one seven in the row uh
and then I played even fop who was
definitely not the strongest player in
the tournament and I was so poor I
couldn't remember the line that went
ages ago there was some form of blackout
so I think that after winning so many
games there inevitable um it's a it's
not it's not um complacency it's you you
you're worn out and uh I have to give
credit to faban Fabiano who played these
two games with Magnus and with Hikaru
with definitely passion determination to
win and he was close hearu is almost by
force and with Magnus he had a dominant
position and it was Magnus who had to
mobilize his his uh uh all his abilities
to survive speaking of that do you feel
that this indicates a real change in
chess these two players 23 and 22 years
old so young as numbers one and two we
can't even remember numbers one and two
being this young are they the future of
Chess is this the championship match you
think is the rifle championship match to
see well I mean it's I don't want to be
provoked to give you an answer you
probably want to hear um I um I always
believe that for the world championship
match to be um to be a really uh an
attractive event for sponsors and for
the public that should include number
one and number two I mean unfortunately
it's now it's you cannot guarantee that
you have both number one and number two
uh uh and uh when Magnus played this
year though it was a world championship
match we all knew that it was very much
one-sided so
um to to have a world championship match
without one of these players and
especially something goes wrong without
both of them I mean will'll serve um no
good for for the world of chess and for
the for the respect of the title going
back just a bit The singfield Cup itself
what do you think about this as a new
addition to the tournament scene yeah um
I I always believe that you know it's
just the the um quality of Chess and and
the fighting Spirit uh uh that's shown
by the players it's it this is something
that uh has NE has never gone and uh I I
was
it was astonishing for me to hear
stories about the end of the game of
chess it's the the BR inevitable and no
energy I mean we could see Magnus who
revitalized the game of chess and now
with Magnus and corana combine you know
it's it's a clear demonstration that the
the classic chess is very much alive the
ornament SEL cup had uh not just many
decisive games it's an amazing Spirit
fighting Spirit shown by all the all the
players and uh and I think that sinful
cup um uh already played and will be
playing a phenomenal role in Reviving or
actually keeping up the reputational
classical chess we know you've been a
fighter all your life you just had one
Journey come to an end what is your next
uh series of of interesting ideas that
you're going to bring to the Chess World
uh now that you moved on from the
politics that you just
finished look you know for me it was not
just politics you know I have to agree
that it was not uh it was not just you
know a political event it was politics
for our opponents that know nothing
about promoting the game but to know how
to attract the vot the votes um now I'm
I still believe that the game of chess
deserves better you know uh people who
are in charge still in charge they um
they are uh not having the interest of
Chess in their heart and uh even if they
had they are not capable of doing things
that are required and um I believe that
in on the current circumstance I have to
find the best algorithm to make sure
that what we proposed in our program
will be somehow
realized you've been traveling the world
talking about kids chess uh promoting
chess on the Scholastic level please
tell us about your efforts there oh it's
still very much in my agenda I have
created a SP of Chess foundations around
the world at five of them in New York
Brussels Johannesburg Singapore and
Mexico City I been not just toi for for
the feated the presidency for me it's
just it's it's a long-term investment I
believe that chess belongs to the to to
the two to the classroom and this is the
future of the game and um well just it's
it's less than a month since we had this
um um event in tromo and um I'm already
thinking about you know future steps to
to energize our programs and looking for
um uh sponsorship both corporate
sponsorship and government support to
make sure that these programs will um
will enter the classroom and I'm quite
optimistic that what we did uh through
the campaign and the investment of our
time and energy will not be
wasted well Gary we always love hearing
from you and the programs that you do
the vision that you have for chess have
been always Majestic always Grand and we
look forward to seeing what you do in
the future thanks so much for joining us
on the show yeah by the way I'm
surprised you didn't ask anything about
the G
oh I I I I didn't want to press I didn't
know if you were following did you did
you have anything to say about the gam I
don't think as much to to comment but
but it's quite amazing that you you ask
about everything except except the games
that are being played as we speak oh I I
I figured uh you had enough to think
about so if you want to make a comment
though on one on one of the games one
game with a draw and I think that Magnus
you know didn't have much of a fighting
spirit
today and then Topo was also quite happy
with his his 50% score and uh I mean the
most interesting game i r in caruana but
I see no no reason to to to
um uh to believe that uh Carana is in
any any any any danger I think it's
roughly even I okay probably yes it's
a I think black is absolutely fine I ask
you what do you think if he draws this
game will this performance go down
among the the greatest ever or is it the
greatest single performance ever given
the
competition uh I would say uh it's
probably the greatest uh I I don't know
how to evaluate the results of the um uh
tournaments played 100 years ago or even
before naturally there were some
phenomenal results but if we talk about
U modern chess including Bob official
performance I mean unless you you um you
um you count the fisher fisher matches
with tar Larson if we look at the
tournaments only I would say it's
probably the most impressive result
considering the strength of the
opposition and also the quality of Chess
I want to to to to to make this comment
again you know it's um you have to be
lucky to play uh Chess at that level and
just to score um such a phenomenal
result and again I didn't see much of
luck in in carono games in fact we we've
mentioned he might have been unlucky to
get the score he has in some ways
because yeah but naturally get this is
the uh it's it's very hard to say
because yeah he was he was winning
against Nakamura he had a very very good
winning chances almost winning against
Magnus uh but at the same time again
this is the way B gra played with him I
mean I I I couldn't avoid by making
sarcastic joke that BWI would kick out
his people from the school for like que4
made
by true uh were you surprised I I want
to make a little twist on this you
surprised by that quick draw however in
this tournament that last round draw I
understand players were tired after 10
rounds but they've been so combative
were you a bit shocked by seeing that
result or is it just you know one out of
all these games played I guess it's
going to be 30 games played that
something like this had to
happen no again um is the from Magnus
and Topo perspective I mean the game had
no um uh no no real
importance yeah and uh I I see no um I
see no reason again this is it's it's
not that they intentionally made a draw
but position was roughly even and they
decided it's probably it's it's worth uh
calling the day off um so um I I'm I'm
not surprised again you can you cannot
ask too much from the players I mean
they fought really hard whole tourament
so um Gary what what game were you most
impressed by for
Fabiano oh it's I think his steadiness
and he played very steady and that's
that's very difficult I mean just
considering the opposition I mean he
just uh he he is well prepared you know
he's not surprised by any opponents uh
ideas in the opening U and uh you know
and then he just he looks for the
chances and he doesn't me them that's
important he he grabs whatever whatever
is available and uh he does it
well well thanks again Gary for your
insights on this on this fantastic
tournament we are quite pleased to see
all your games going over your games
even now quite a treat for your fighting
Spirit we can only hope that this
generation continues your legacy uh that
you've created for the game okay thank
you okay thank you very much so sorry
sorry couldn't be with you we're we're
definitely sorry too thanks so much
World former world champion Gary
Kasparov one of the greatest players of
all time joining us on the show back to
you Jen and yes thank you that was
marvelous to have Gary casprov on the
show and I I love his recent campaign
that he did on Twitter why I love chess
he encouraged people to hashtag I love
why I love chess and explain and you
just got this marvelous uh combination
of responses nice from all levels of
competition like Grand Masters were
responding and people who had just
picked up the game were responding and
so it's great that even though he's
involved in so many different things
human rights politics he's he's always
got Chess at the on his on his mind at
the Forefront of his mind yeah exactly
always a treat to hear from Gary and for
all of his good works again a shout out
most especially to the Kasparov chess
Foundation um all around the world from
Southeast Asia Africa
and of course here in America the
casparo foundation encourages chess and
schools and so as long as Fabiano
doesn't screw it up
today according to Gary casparo this is
the most impressive Tournament of all
time and that's High Praise indeed so we
can't lose today though no that would
ruin it yeah that would be a real real
sour note uh what we have seen by the
way in the game between leavon aronian
uh trades have been made made back here
at this moment I thought that leavon was
going to play a little bit more quieter
a move like for example Bishop F3 B6
King G2 just getting his King and pardon
me getting his King out of the way so
that the queen and Rook could be
connected uh if we saw a move like
Bishop B7 E4 to keep as many pieces on
the board leavon struck out very quickly
however with the move E2 E4 possibly
playing for ideas like E4 E5 and queen
G4 trying to snap this Pawn on H6
playing for a kingside attack that was
neatly nipped in the bud by the way with
this move E5 I like this move very much
by Fabiano uh just slowing white uh the
king side uh takes takes F4 trade of
queens and this it's always nice to
develop with a Tempo Bishop G4 so even
though this bishop is hanging at the
moment white has to decide where he
wants to place his Rook first of all um
still having said all of this I do think
leavon has a slight pull but uh easier
chances for um uh fabbiano to equalize
and draw the position right and in
Caspar's opinion the best ever wow the
strongest ever and the best ever um we
are going to take a little break now and
we do have a puzzle for you this is
Nakamura crash so we'll be back with
that and with the final games here from
the 2014 singfield
[Music]
cup
I'm Maxim V and you're watching the sink
field Cup live in St
Louis welcome back to the 2014 sink
field cup I'm Jennifer sh I'm here with
Grandmaster yaser Saran um how do we get
better than Magnus and Gary in one hour
or in 10
minutes I don't know but if you have the
answer you know let me know the secret
formula well that was pretty awesome and
we do have a a puzzle that you guys
solved over the break Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley has the answer to the
question between Hikaru Nakamura and
Grandmaster Irena crash as you mentioned
I wrote I said Nakamura Crush which uh
could be a d double meaning
indeed and was it both in this case
Maurice indeed it was my fellow
brooklynite Grandmaster enena Crush has
one of the great names in chess of
course that name Crush she has used to
good effect to getting her Grandmaster
title becoming the first woman in the
all of the Americas to become a
Grandmaster however in this game uh not
so much the name meant something quite
different uh in this game and in this
position of course who is she playing
Hikaru Nakamura a few of us have been
crushed by him before well in this
position of course you can see the
superiority of White's pieces white has
Knight Queen Bishop and Rook well placed
in the meantime their black counterparts
on the wrong side of the planet as far
as this position is concerned this poor
King totally exposed was now fully
denuded by a big time shot Knight takes
F7 bam opening up this kingside blasting
the last shred at least the the back
Pawn the one you think you should at
least be able to hold well now it's gone
in this position she could not capture
back with King takes on F7 because then
she would get mated quite quickly after
Queen takes E6 check and where to put
the king king f8 certainly doesn't work
because of Checkmate in two moves notice
again how the black pieces just stand
helplessly on this side of the board not
able to do anything about it and of
course the option here after Queen takes
E6 check if she were to try to run to G
G7 well welcome to the party says the
rook and the black king just gets
attacked mercilessly until it is
checkmated unfortunately she could not
capture back this night when it captured
on F7 but to not take this Knight and to
leave this E6 Pawn weak with the move
Knight to D5 could not have been
constructive because after Queen takes
E6 Queen takes on F7 Queen takes C6 she
actually resigned after this move Queen
takes C6 cuz she saw Queen takes C6 and
every single black piece is under attack
this Knight three times attacked this
one this bishop this rook and you might
even count these two pieces under attack
because of that long diagonal really
vicious finish to this game a nice
Sacrifice by Nakamura Knight takes F
seven I'm sure all of you out there saw
you've been watching nine rounds of the
singfield cup you definitely got the
solution to this one I might add Jen as
a Young Man growing up in Brooklyn
loving chess reading about the Champions
to actually sit in a chair and and
interview Magnus Carlson world champion
and Gary Kasparov I mean that's just a
thrill of a lifetime so it's it's just
amazing what can happen when you live
your dreams guys thank you Maurice I I
have to second that as well I feel like
I've got the best job in the world
sitting here watching the most thrilling
epic uh tournament performance we've
witnessed in modern chess and having
I mean even yesterday like it was a
different it was different but it was
also absolutely amazing that some of
those endgame U motifs there by Magnus
and the cool thing about that was that
the engine didn't understand the
position so we were kind of like all on
our own and trying to figure that out
right well I liked also when Magnus was
explaining his game today uh a short
draw to be sure but he said that the
engines didn't understand this Berlin
ending and I thought that was fair very
insightful as well and true listen I
mean the the the real pure end games are
going to understand because of the table
bases but other types of end games there
can be some real misunderstandings right
like just thinking leavon was totally
lost right it was like minus five or
something during the uh the cor defense
yeah chess a chess fan stopped me on my
way into the club and he looked at me
with wied Di explor and saying wow how
how did
leavon saved the game he was three pawns
down and it was really um fun fun just
the chess fans coming and watching the
games uh after that wonderful sparkling
uh tactical brilliancy by uh Hikaru in
the puzzle we have a game going on which
is a
strategic uh fight that's going on here
and I like what hikaru's has done
normally speaking what do you call them
I call them the two two bees you call
them the two shaboo the two shaboo
normally the two shaboo get uh High
marks uh for um compensation however the
really what is going on in this
particular game is white is trying to uh
press black on the D6 Pawn as well as
the pawn on A5 and use this wonderful
outpost on his Knight on D5 there's
going to be a case where the two Bishops
aren as strong as the two knights it's
going to be when you have an absolutely
perfect Knight right exactly you can't
do better right and uh this bishop on H6
while
it's um it has a good diagonal there's
nothing really on that diagonal and uh
let me just put a a position on the
board uh that I want to
show if white can start reorganizing his
pieces to really drill down on this Pawn
on D6 for example to play moves like
Rook D3 Rook D1 Knight B5 and go after
this Pawn on D6 Maxine could find
himself strategically
lost uh without and he's going to have
to uh get his own counter chances and
those counter chances have to uh re
evolve revolve around the move F7 F5
which also has the potential of EXP in
his King to risk so I do like
strategically uh what Hikaru has done in
this game and I'm not saying that Rook
A8 is the best move perhaps we do have a
move uh yet I'm I think a few moves have
been played just a second let me see let
me get my after Queen A6 Rook C8 Queen
okay so the last few moves Queen
A6 uh Rook A8 in fact was played Queen
A2 Rook back to C8 and again I just see
this idea from White that it's very
compelling to bring your Rook on F1
which is a little bit passive into the
game and when you do this Rook D3 it
also squelches a lot of uh any kingside
initiatives that uh black may be
dreaming up uh CU You' got this Rook G3
interference type of moves and if white
can press Maxine and press him on this
D6 Pawn uh White will have a significant
Advantage very very much so and I don't
think we're going to see another
Perpetual in this game or rep A6 rade is
not in the cards no indeed certainly not
and in our game with our tournament
champion uh Fabiana Karana uh we when we
left it we left it at the moment where
Fabiana had traded queens and just
played this move Bishop G4 attacking
White's rook and leavon has a difficult
ult uh decision to make right here he
eventually after a lot of thinking
played the move Rook on D1 to D5 and
probably did it with a heavy heart
because he knows that as soon as this
bishop moves that Rook on D5 is an
immediate Target for this bishop to drop
back and guess what there's a potential
weakness on A2 so after the move Bishop
B2 do we have a move by leavon not quite
presumably he'd like to play something
like A4 with the idea of playing A5 but
how does that turn out does that become
even weaker I guess the problem is when
you play Bishop E6 now yeah well at the
moment you still haven't developed your
king and Rook so for example I might if
I were in black shoes here I might want
to switch strategies and bring a rook to
C8 I'm not too sure which Rook with the
idea that because your King still hasn't
gotten off
the gotten out of the way for The Rook
on H1 that uh this a counter uh attack
with Rook C2 in the position I'll keep
this move Bishop E6 for the moment in
reserve and it looks like Fabiano is
actually uh stands extremely well uh in
that case we do have a move I believe
and Bish B2 was played pardon me yes we
do have Bishop B5 Rook B5 okay uh going
after this bishop I think that was a
very good move by the way because the
Rook does get out of this attack that we
mentioned that we would likely see after
Bishop E6 yeah so yeah leavon good with
these little Shifty Rooks huh yeah like
yesterday um you know I was thinking
about the vanore defense and how you
were saying that you need to know it but
actually sometimes it's not that easy to
figure out how to execute it right you
have to figure out how to like shift
your Rook over so Leon really pounced in
that moment to play Rook B3 to B5 yeah
and this is just something that
separates I would say worldclass Grand
Masters many Grand Masters uh are aware
of course of the defense but then just
to recognize it instantly in that that
moment that you need it the most you
know right to set it up to set it up and
to just be aware of it have it in the
Forefront of your mind um
uh is why he's such a world class uh
grandm I'm kind of wondering actually
did this move Bishop C Bishop
B2 uh was that really the best move by
Fabiano I would have thought that he
would want to
keep that Bishop
um out of the way of the rook in other
words not let the Rook escape with the
tempo so for example if I had if faon
had just dropped back with his Bishop F6
you make this move E4 E5 very compelling
but now the Bish Bishop is unassailable
and again I'm thinking that black should
be thinking about his own counterplay
the bishop on B2 makes a kind of a
strange impression it's just like
hovering in midair over there and you're
kind of asking yourself what is the
bishop be doing so I like this move Rook
D5 and I'm assuming that Fabiano's
intention is to play Bishop A3 to
somehow put his Bishop on a square where
maybe one day when he has Rook C8 he'll
be able to play Bishop C5 um
still is not so clear to me after Rook
continuing to attack the bishop well I
guess you get the bishop back to E7
after all and I think Fabi is doing very
well and I think Mar Ashley has some
thoughts on this game as
well yes you're absolutely right the
engines are slowly liking black more and
more and more by the move and the inin
are not impressed by this move Rook to
B5 in fact and think that you are
correct Bishop to A3 very simply just
rerouting the bishop it can only be so
harassed after Rook to B3 all these
moves don't matter and finally black has
stabilized the position of the bishop no
more threats to that piece and black is
ready to just bring some Rooks into the
game the key here of these two pawns
this majority two to one on this side if
these start to roll down the board they
could go very fast uh down the board and
white will have to be careful because
these four pawns they don't look that
impressive anymore in fact the engin are
trying to figure out how the heck to
trade off this bishop because this
bishop is a bone in the throat very
annoying you might have to somehow make
bishop H3 work and you have to worry
about this move Bishop takes Pawn that
could be an interesting line of course
we don't want to see this happen this
this would be the worst thing to happen
we don't want to see this at all that
repetition but black could play Bishop
takes Pawn here and uh his Bishop is
kind of sideline in the position
although you can't quite trap it
completely uh with these moves but you
may not want to let this happen on the
board although it does look like black
has W upon pawn and it's not so easy uh
White will eventually have to face F6
but could play E6 pretty crazy position
except for this kind of weird uh
discombobulation of pieces so black
might just trade all the way back here
the very first time it happened black
might just trade actually can just trade
and still wi pieces are discoordinated
these pieces leave a very bad impression
as a matter of fact even though the game
is fairly close black could play this
move and it'll be up to White to make
sure he doesn't face two evil black
Rooks coming into the position really
fast and just keeping this position
solid a move like Rook back to H2 for
example controlling everything so it's
white here at least according to the
engines who is concerned about maybe
going into a worse position and black
well cool calm Carana once again with a
good position have we seen him in
trouble at any point in this entire
tournament I mean he could have been N9
and0 and he's starting to put a little
bit of pressure on seeking uh that
possibility of nine out of 10 that would
be a decent score decent normal and
absolutely historic according to many um
pundits including none other than Gary
cast
who uh certainly has done the research
for my great predecessors um we've got
some reactions from our Twitter audience
uh Joseph Levine says forget about the
two shabo we poker players call them
pocket Bishops go Bishops I like it I
like that I like that and we also have
Grandmaster Susan pogar who says that
carolana has a very comfortable position
with black vers ceron on and he is way
ahead on time oh yeah the time
differences uh half an hour extremely
significant at this level yes so good
point by Susan and uh we also have Danny
wrench from chess.com who says that
there's so many chess fans from around
the world in the St Louis chess club at
the S Cup today it makes you feel so
good about the future of our game and
many of them children uh not only here
at the club watching The Players live
but also kicking back at lesters where
apparently vessel hope I was already
join enjoying a post tournament cocktail
and at the World Chess Hall of Fame
where
you have grand Masters Ben fold and
Alejandra Ramirez giving you blowby blow
details of what's happening it's a funny
uh line that Maurice was mentioning and
I don't see a repetition I Believe by
the way Bishop H3 was played by uh
leavon there's a very enterprising line
here that I like for Fabiano very much
the enterprising line is Bishop H3
attacking the bishop Bishop F3 attacking
the Rook as well as a Pawn on e4
bringing back that Bishop to G2 and
how's this for a nice move Bishop D1
keeping the position alive and the idea
is that after King F2 you gain a Tempo
against the bishop you develop
everybody's happy but then comes this
move Bishop A4 The Rook has to find a
place D5 looks reasonable uh B1 looks
reasonable but after all of the
reasonable moves at the end of the day I
still like what Maurice was saying Rook
fc8 bringing uh a rook onto the open
file and Maurice was mentioning you got
to be careful these pawns on the queen
side when they move you they move real
fast A5 B B5 they get they get going
very
quickly in the meantime this bishop on
G2 and this Rook on H1 still have to uh
be brought into the game and these
Bishops that look strange on A4 and A3
do control a lot of squares so
uh I like fana's position and I don't
think he's going to go for this
repetition even though it would secure
him um the greatest
tpr uh we've ever seen tournament
performance rating I mean when I say tpr
by the way got to cement that record so
that it's much harder to beat and uh we
do have so many special guests in town
for the weekend here at the singfield
cup you know it is also uh got ultimate
moves on Monday I'm looking forward to
that one and uh in addition to it being
Grandmaster Ben fal's birthday today
tomorrow it is chess club president and
founder Rex sinfield's birthday at
70 very respectable Rex indeed and uh
one special guest we have in town is the
world famous photographer Harry Benson
he's photographed The Beatles he's
photographed US presidents and he's also
photographed Bobby Fisher and he talked
to Taran about that
all right I am here with Mr Harry Benson
photographer extraordinaire you have
photographed The Beatles presidents and
also Bobby fiser what made him so
unique because he was the greatest in
the
world and he took on the
[Music]
world alone nobody helped
him and I've never met a personality
like him I never will in life how would
you we were
friends okay yes I mean tell us about
that he was a very private person and he
allowed you into his world to photograph
him he led me into his world because of
one thing very Charming actually no but
for one thing was I knew nothing about
Chess and anybody that spoke chess to
him Bobby thought was a
he did
really and so I I no I mean not only did
I know nothing about
chance I had no clue yeah you know but
he respected you as a friend well he
knew that I photographed other things
you know like the be like Richard Nixon
like Joe namoth of the Jets he was he
was
Bobby was a bit of a j was a bit of um
what I what would I say uh he loved
sport love boxing I like to hear about
Muhammad
Ali love his stories because I cover
Deli in a lot of his
fights and
um so that's what we talked about you
know I knew would I wouldn't get
anywhere near Chest God no just to two
friends hanging out enjoying each
other's company yes walking around um in
the fields of
Iceland um I remember one night figh it
right at the beginning of the tournament
Bobby played badly and they
thought you know not really
badly and he get
beaten and um we were walking in Iceland
and just talking away and he just
stopped he said you know Harry tomorrow
I'm going to crush him crush him that
was spasy and that's what he did he
crushed them what an amazing story and
I'm sure you have wonderful Stories
Behind These photographs if you any of
these really stick out in your memory
this was an
Argentina and uh see he had a
chest board with them all the time you
see there was a little pocket thing he
would bring
out that was when he made the terrible
error with spasy in the first game then
he told me he was going to crush him you
know out like at 3:00 in the morning
with the Midnight Sun in um
Iceland that is very neat any of do
these two photographs over here stick
out to
you triumphant he won he just he won and
but he was still going
through you know the games that he lost
where he where he shouldn't have lost
you
know but I wanted to do a portrait like
that because he's a scary guy you know
he really is you
don't you know he's going to crush
somebody you know and I don't want it to
be me or you you know
he he was aware of this it very much
sums up his personality and his career
yes that's right it
was he knew what he was doing yeah and
he wanted to be taken like an athlete
like an Ali like Joe neus like um a
great Sportsman because he considered it
a sport of course yes it you know it
wasn't it wasn't fun been sitting down
there and that's why he kept himself
physically
fit
because it's
very very
tiring yes that's you know that's what
you would tell me about it he said it's
like running Miles and Miles you know
and then you photographed him just like
an athlete and now your photographs hang
here in the World Chess Hall of Fame
very honored that they're here you know
and thank for you're saying the nice
things about me of course well thank you
for joining us we really appreciate it
Mr Benson it's a pleasure I'll come up
again next time thank you thank you Jen
back to you wow that was an incredible
interview with Harry Benson Taran schaer
just a really beautiful I mean you know
that you know that he's 84 years old
wonderful I mean I love the oral history
in chess too I have the stories of Bobby
and what we did and I'm like all ears
and each and every time somebody has
something very fascinating and
insightful to say and just that comment
that Bobby thought everybody was a
I just love that that was just great and
by the way just a a little story about
the picture where Bobby's on the flight
he has the pocket set open and he's got
a position so at the opening ceremony
vesselin topof called called me over and
said there's a mistake in the photograph
and I said really he said yeah come on
over so we go over and he says look at
the chess position there's a white King
on the E8 square and says look they did
something wrong and I said no so that
particular set that Bobby was holding
was a very famous set that was
manufactured in buen airis Argentina
it's a leather set and you move these
uh you slide these plastic pieces inside
unfortunately this particular plastic
that they used was very brittle I love
these chest sets and I had quite a
number of them myself and you often
broke the pieces so you had these extra
pieces so if you broke two blacks black
kings you would take a white king and
replace it on the as a black king so I
was explaining this to vessel and he
said oh of course you're absolutely
right and it goes to show that Bobby
really used that set a great deal
because uh a lot of the pieces were
chipped wow broken so kind of insightful
story on story photograph yeah Bobby
wasn't going to let that slide no I mean
it's not going to stop him for playing
chess he just needed another piece to
replace the black king exactly wow so
good stuff I could tell you tons and
tons of stories about Bobby but he um
the photo photographer was absolutely
right Bobby was very very intense man
and he really viewed chess as a sport
that required uh a very fit physical
conditioning and for those of you who
have seen Bobby Fischer versus the rest
of the world the that uh documentary
which is brilliant by the way uh many
many photographs uh that I hadn't seen
before where he's swimming in a pool
especially there's one in the shower
too a little uh a little Paro Guidance
the parents showing it to their kids
woohoo um turning back to the games by
the way Hikaru Nakamura took a a little
bit of a different approach than what I
had thought uh Rook C8 Queen okay so we
go back to this position and I had uh
basically expected whoops just a second
this move Queen
E2 and oh he hikaro ended up placing his
Queen on the D3 Square I really thought
that Hikaru was going to double his
Rooks and pressure that D6 Pawn he
spotted a different idea behind uh a way
of of pressuring the D6 Pawn he's played
the move Knight B5 and what he's
anticipating is the sliding with the
queen over to A3 moving this Knight out
of the way so everything so putting
everything on D6 so for example if we
saw a move like Rook C5 I have it in
mind that Hikaru spotted A variation
like this where at the end of these
trades this Pawn on D6 sticks out like a
sore thumb and thanks to this Knight on
B5 this queen on A3 White's ready to
pick off this Pawn on D6 now meanwhile
black tries to defend it on C6 that
looks uh like by placing Rook to C6 like
right here could get a little bit
dangerous but let's see how with that
yeah I would say that I think hikaru's
got ideas like Queen A3 Rook Rook Rook
D3 Rook C3 D3 Rook over and even this
move one one of the things that
unfortunately you would love to do is to
expose this Pawn to a direct attack by
the Knight and the queen but you're
walking into this bishop C4 uh skure of
this Rook so even this idea of B4 in a
situation where the Rook was under
attack um is an is is possible but I
think that uh hikaru's idea of Queen
A3 um a little bit too aggressive for my
taste I like the the queen back on E2
and the double of Rooks uh but hikaro uh
great calculator let's hope that he's
calculated something very good for
himself now meanwhile Maxim Basher the
grab has already responded with Rook to
C6 so he is kind of anticipating that
he's going to want to shore up that pawn
on D6 exactly so The Rook comes up to
and um um it's up to hikaro to decide
how he wants to treat this specific
position does he want to put his Queen
we're always tell our students and with
good reason um keep your pieces
centralized and uh this move Queen
A3 violates a little bit of that rule
but for very specific reasons he may
want to do that another idea and a
different approach by the way would be
to play the move Knight E3 again with
this idea of a frontal attack and maybe
even B2 B3 followed by Knight E3 to C4
uh has strategical justifications you
want to play against this dark s Bishop
which is way over there on the other
side now if we play the move Knight to
A7 after Rook to C6 oh I'm sorry yes me
play for a moment you can't uh you your
protection of D6 is is removed because
you can't stay on that diagonal I mean
you can't stay on that rank right right
but the problem is now Rook C5 and our
Knight is in the way from capturing it
so it doesn't look like this leads to
anything in
well just a second
maybe before there's still the uh Bishop
C4 thing right there's still the bishop
C4 and the Knight the Knight no longer
is anchored so yeah that's might be just
a little bit of an overreach and just
again we were looking at the variation
that if if it wasn't for the fact that
our Rook was on F1 B4 might be a strong
move here yeah and then after Knight B4
we're we're hitting the D6 pawn and
we're ready to come to C6 but uh Bishop
C4 is the that party yeah unfortunate so
okay so uh still uh Hikaru again needs a
needs to end this tournament on a high
note a very disappointing tournament
obviously for America's number one and
he needs to see if this move Queen A3
this ambitious idea of targeting that
pawn on D6 is going to work should we
move back to
our our champion yeah yeah and the light
squ Bishops were were traded off let's
see how that happened so after Bishop
H3
uh Fabiana simply captured that Bishop I
thought that he might play this move
Bishop F3 pulling this bishop back and
then keeping the Bishops on the board
but that fbana said no I've spotted
something in the position Bishop takes
Rook C8 I think uh Maurice got to this
position recommended Rook H2 and uh
White tries to batten down the hatches
can he do it
Maurice well yes sir I often teach my
students that trades are generally the
bane of weaker players's games that is
people love to trade kids when they play
chess what what's one of the main
reasons why they play chess so they can
eat stuff like there's a bishop take it
there's a rook take it doesn't matter if
it's a good trade or not just take it it
you're getting stuff you're collecting
stuff on your side as you become a
better player you have to become more
nuanced in these trades and in fact
trades become horrible things to do uh
if you're just being done automatically
I tell my students trades are either
forc or fantastic I won't tell you what
the other fi tell them is if it's not a
good trade so this position actually I
don't tell my students that my older
students my adults uh this trade here
Bishop takes H3 is a controversial one
it is defin Ely possible and it is very
close to the computer's First Choice the
computer actually waivers between this
is the first choice and the other move
your idea yes of Bishop to D1 uh it it
actually likes this trade because of the
speed with which the Rooks come into the
game Bishop takes H3 was played if we
may look at another line though instead
of Bishop F3 as which brings the bishop
back into the game the white Bishop
Bishop D1 immediately now I know
positionally you want to play Bishop F3
so that this bishop would become
deactivated would stop controled the C8
Square for example but this bishop
actually the black pieces don't
necessarily need C8 the d8 square would
be enough but more importantly it's the
speed of this bishop in attacking this E
Pawn that the the computer likes and the
fact now is that the threats come very
fast Bishop A4 is indeed a threat in the
position if the Rook leaves and attacks
the bishop doesn't change anything this
bishop wants to go here and it's headed
to this Square where he can attack this
Pawn on e4 it turns out that white right
now can defend the position with the
move with a move like like uh Rook to D4
getting ready for this move but guess
who's ready to strike with the move F5
how do you like that idea lurking in the
position so white has to be a little bit
careful here to make sure that doesn't
happen moves like Bishop to D7 don't
quite work because the bishop will just
drop back and this Pawn is feeling some
tender effect now white can actually
just play King here and get ready for
these kinds of moves F5 no longer works
in the position because of a move like
check and the King moves out the way and
then you can play a move like this very
easily defending the position so the the
attack on the E Pawn just doesn't quite
fit uh it doesn't get enough done which
is why after calculating in this
position Bishop to A3 Bishop
H3 the young man said you know what I
don't need any other hassle let me just
take this piece off the board and go for
a speedy attack along the long diagonals
Rook along the files Rook over Rook over
and the Rooks now beautifully placed the
computer is still only giving this a
very very slight Edge actually almost in
negligable Edge after Rook back Bishop
E7 so it seems as though the balance in
the position is pretty much restored
you've got to like Black's position is
no problem at all but it looks like
white can just bring his Rook into the
game and the players are headed towards
a draw which would cement karan's
performance as the greatest tournament
performance rating wise in the history
of the game guys thank you
Maurice wonderful strategic fight in
this battle of ideas and when you just
look visually at the position you have
to applaud Fabiano's Rooks Rook C8 Rook
d8 controlling the center file something
that we always tell
our our charges H whereas White Rooks a
bit uncoordinated on these B5 and and H2
squares and that's why Maurice was
saying very important that white
uh regroups his Rooks to better squares
and brings his King up F2 I do feel
however that this game is heading
towards a draw and that meanwhile
Nakamura has played the move Queen A3
pressurizing D6 right so he found this
kind of I I like the idea of the
doubling Rooks sorry to keep repeating
myself and leaving the queen in a better
centralized situation however aaru very
deep calculator he is looking at
variations where this queen which is
temporarily off sides will uh Bear Down
on the D6 pawn and he feels that uh the
queen decentralized does a lot more uh
on A3 and that was a very good idea I'm
still not 100% sure about it myself
about how he really kind of increases
the advantage almost like he needs to
create a new weakness because black has
figured out how to hold on to that D6
Pawn exactly exactly uh on the other
hand again I'm I'm sitting here saying
well it's one thing to sit here and
defend and defend and defend it's
another uh to create your own counter
chances I thought that at some point
Maxine was going to have to play the
move F7 F5 five to develop threats on
the king side of course that's a
double-edged move uh anytime you open up
the position usually it's in the favor
of the player who is best better
developed um this case it's kind of hard
to say who is best developed as both
players have uh the pieces off the back
ring and with the exception Queen on da
we've seen some major movement in this
tournament in the live ratings list yeah
in this particular game now kamora um if
if he wins he'll not be in in last right
in last place in the tournament he'll be
tied for last instead correct um so
that'll be a little bit of a money swing
as well something like $5,000 I mean not
uh the most relevant but on the other
hand he has nothing to lose in a way
because if he loses or draws it's either
way it's last place okay butting points
but I think Jen weren't you mentioning
to me yesterday that his uh one of his
key competitors uh for the position on
the rankings that he has is mvl right
and there's only like a one or twoo
difference between them if MV can can
can win this game he would of course
Leap Frog over uh that's right you see
that right in front of us that uh hiar
Nakamura is only one point ahead in the
live rankings list of Maxim vashir lrav
and other big Movement we saw of course
was favano Carana soaring to 2835 in
this event Magnus Carlson losing a few
points he's now less than 30 points
higher than Fabiano kowana and that's
even with Fabiano missing that Victory
yesterday so incredible progress yeah I
know well again uh before the tournament
Fabiano uh became one of the very few
players in the world to ever cross the
2800 line he had just made it at 2801
coming into the the event and then
suddenly and out of the blue gaining 35
rating points at this level is
absolutely unheard of
2835 and he's cementing his uh stamp on
the world's best players with his
performance here now meanwhile hear
Nakamura struggling to stay in the top
10 but looks like the wrong direction
yes he's finding some form uh late in
the tournament and we do have a couple
moves in that game where Maxim Basher
lra seems to be in the defensive um has
played Queen to D7 M so bringing his
Queen and potentially setting up for
threats like Bishop H3 certainly aware
that the queen does uh cover the pawn on
H3 and after Bishop
H3 uh a soft move Rook on F1 to E1 by
hakaru uh
just bringing the Rook to a better
Square
trying to limit the effects of what
might happen should maxing go uh a
little Whole Hog on the king side with
F7 F5 again I'm looking for more
effective development uh by hikaro I
thought once
again pardon me uh sorry to keep
repeating myself I'm begging hakaru to
dle his Rooks on the defile and get that
uh that going uh by by the way one of
the nice points about Rook e one and it
does deserve mention it does get out of
any of those future skes our Queen's on
A3 not D3 so not quite as relevant
now yes true true that but
it it's always good to develop and then
figure out later why you develop yes
just like castling right exactly and we
are going to take a quick break and
we'll be back with more from the 2014
sinkfield cup including some more
information on a very special event that
we have here coming up on Monday
ultimate moves which is going to feature
the sink Fields um in fact Rex singfield
and his son Randy as well as all six
competitors in the singfield cup and
Yasser so stay tuned for more
information on that and of course the uh
final games here and round
[Music]
10 until recently chess was like
this chess 24 brought you this live
interactive broadcasts from Top
tournaments with computer analysis and
video commentary by the likes of yan
Gustafson Lawrence Trent and Peters
Fiddler a Play Zone where you can take
on opponents from all around the world
24/7 interactive beginners courses
ensuring you pick up the basics fast
while having fun a tactics trainer to
sharpen your chest by solving puzzles
adapted to your level hundreds of
interactive videos letting you watch and
learn from Star players such as Vish
Anand Peter fidler pacoo and who you
fan you've given up on that outdated
computer that's why there are more
reasons to use chess 24 on mobiles and
tablets full Play Zone access including
pre-move a tactics trainer so you can
stay sharp wherever you are computer
opponents you can challenge even when
you're not online live broadcasts of top
chess
events and the half it's free well
that's half true most features are free
but limited for registered members for a
mere $13.99 per month however you can
step up to premium membership and gain
unlimited access to our video library
that and much
more make chess 24 your
[Music]
playground
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagine it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
worldclass art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art
experience I'm mnus Carlson and you're
watching the sinkfield Cup live here
from St
Louis welcome back to the 2014 sinkfield
cup it's almost over we are so sad but
I'm afraid I'm going to crash down to
earth uh after these two weeks of high
Thrills and uh meeting all these players
and being part of all the festivities
that are going on on here I'm going to
have to go back to my mundane life after
this oh which isn't very mundane I'm
sure post what are they postpartum post
tournament depression there you go
that's what I'm fearful that I'm going
to face in our game and here's the crew
that put this all together look at look
at that we've got Randy sinkfield you'll
be seeing from him yesterday do you see
aen there we've got Kevin we've got our
sound Guy Brian Tammy k um just a
fantastic Tom the director of the show
Brian he's the new uh communications
director here at the club so um and of
course you see Taran there front and
center absolutely and Maurice and
Maurice looks like he was photoshopped
in it looks like too perfect yeah we got
we got to squeeze ince and Maurice just
looks too perfect right kind of like in
honor of Mr Perfect there you go just
trying to be like Fabby I want to be
like to be decob to be decent um in the
game of Fabiano and leavon ronian uh the
game uh more trades are on the in the
offing here and I do see this going into
a double Rook end game and a rather even
one at that so this last
move pardon me this last move by um
leavon Bishop oops I got to get there we
go so Bishop came down to C1 and leavon
very happy to get this Rook that had
been in the corner virtually the entire
game is now back in the game if we were
to see a trade Bishop takes Rook takes
at least white is coordinating his Rooks
finally he's going to play King F2 and
he's going to go E5
E6 um and I think more trades are in the
offing and this game uh borrowing any
unforeseen major errors should go to a
draw and it was leavon who found some
clever Rook Maneuvers just like last
game of course not quite as deep as
yesterday right to extricate himself
from maybe a slightly uncomfortable
position and uh
finally yay I'm glad to see it uh we do
have uh the idea for Hikaru to double
his Rooks on the defile so we go back to
this moment uh Rook E1 I thought of as a
little bit of a soft move uh and then
finally Rook D3 so again it's very very
clear that Hikaru wants to uh position
as many of his forces as he can direct
them uh to the control of uh to the
attack on the D6 Pawn one of the things
I'm worried about is that first of all
since he's wasted a few moves doing this
black might for example play Rook C8 and
Rook C1 getting uh some of the pressure
off the position also this move Bishop
G5 pardon me I just did want to say that
yeah it does in I have to make a move
for black in certain variations it
covers that key E7 Square as well right
it it um mvls ready to drop back and
then you start to worry that well maybe
you didn't put your queen you know you
you have to be Larry that a D6 D5
suddenly doesn't come as a real real
shock so I didn't like the queen on A3
but overall I still think that he caros
for choice in this position now teren
actually outside with Tony Rich the
executive director of the chess club
here in St Louis to tell us a little bit
about this exhibition match that we're
going to have on Monday ultimate
moves yes thank you Jen so the ultimate
moves on Monday kind of explain how that
works to people sure so ultimate moves
Monday is a tandem chess uh series of
games in which our Club founder Rex
singfield will play against his son
Randy singfield now each will have a
bench of four grand Masters that will
rotate in helping them alternating
making moves along the way so the big
question is which of the two amateur
players will end up making the best
moves and win the match that's really
fun and then Tuesday is Ultimate
Showdown right Ultimate Showdown is an
exhibition match between aaro Nakamura
and lean aronian in which they will play
Fisher random chess or chess 960 where
you jumble all the pieces on the back
row and they start from a brand new
position that neither player has seen
before no opening Theory no studying
just two brains against each other
and people can still watch these events
on the live stream yes you can watch the
events on live stream we'll have some
recorded analysis that uh Grandmaster
yaser camon Jennifer shahadi and Maurice
Ashley will uh produce for us and that
will follow up after the chest 960 match
between aronian and Nakamura it's a
great way to end a tournament that has
just been fabulous here at the CH chess
tournament it's been so exciting you
know the singfield cup is always my
favorite event and I'm already looking
forward to what will happen next year
great well so are we thank you for
joining us Tony and make sure and tune
in on Monday and Tuesday for the
exhibition matches Jen thank you to tan
and Tony and you're gonna be seeing a
lot of him tomorrow but here he is Randy
sinkfield the founder of spectrum
Studios producing this this this live
stream and he's with Maurice Ashley and
he's gonna be trash talking his own dad
now how how cool is that you get to play
against your dad and a slew of other
Grandmasters uh Randy feeling feeling
very about himself being able to
participate in a competition like that
guys he looks happy to me yeah well uh R
Randy of course on his team as he faces
his father on the 70th birthday he's got
to he's going to have a very formidable
team the Randy and I have already
scheduled a training to get him in that
eye of the tiger mode that he needs to
bring his aame and to beat his dad on
his 70th birthday you know it's it's a
dream come true for r
now we are will be a come true for we're
going to have live stream coverage on
Monday and sinast is going to be
participating in the exhibition um
Grandmaster Alejandro Ramirez is going
to be replacing you wonderful
replacement and uh I expect a colorful
shirt yes of course as always of course
you're irreplaceable though we we'll
we'll miss you but in a way you'll still
be here yeah because you'll be out there
making moves I'll be throwing the
patties and then of course uh Grand
Master Mar sleia will be here uh to kind
of pinpoint perhaps some slightly weaker
moves than we're used to seeing here at
the sinkfield car possibly not the same
feels but just by you guys because
you're going to be playing under such
big time pressure well exactly well it's
a team event you know and I really don't
like to take advantage of my opponents
but I mean I actually have a lot of
experience in these uh Team events I
just uh teamed up with zuan grandmas
zuan of China for this mix doubles event
that we uh tied for first in so well
okay uh I'll have more experience than
everybody else in the event now as for
Tuesday that's really cool because
that's a a playoff of Bobby Fisher right
we've got the Bobby Fisher show and now
we've got Fisher random or chess 960
right however that won't be a live
stream show but there will be some
coverage of it so you can read and
follow analysis of it later where hi car
and the V so he car Mor and Leon on two
massive lovers of variance from Bug
House to chess 960 um I'm still want a
little Bug House challenge I I got to do
a slapd down I want hikaro on my team
and I'm willing to go up against leavon
and Fabiano and teach them how Americans
play Bug House boy that would be great
yeah I can't wait to see how those games
turn out though the chess n60 but not
the your last chance to catch a live
stream show here where you get all the
play by play that will be on Monday so
some of you have said that you're sad
about the in cup ending but there's a
little bit more fun for you absolutely
fun still more fun in games I should
also remind everyone that there's a
press conference that will follow 30
minutes after this game ends so yes
there will be a press conference over at
lesters with all of the players so
you're not really going to want to miss
that that should be interesting and some
other questions uh for these players
including maybe some things that we
haven't gotten a chance to ask them
during the event absolutely and that
would be very nice as all the play
the journalists will have their
questions at the ready and big questions
too uh about the future of the World
Championship uh we'll uh we'll get those
ones asked and answered as well I have
no idea but uh we do have a lot of
journalists in town right grandm Gan Ian
Rogers I almost said Grandmaster Gan
think grandmas and I kind of Blended the
words together but we had do have Grand
Master for Ian Rogers he's writing for
many Publications including chess life
and chess life online we also have
chess.com journalists you know chess 24
everywhere Durk Durk from here a
fantastic journalist exactly so this
will be an exciting uh press conference
and I'm sure you'll want to watch that
one as well indeed so who knows when
it's going to start it really depends on
I think how this Yar Nakamura Maxim Vash
lra game starts to spin out because I
don't think the uh Ronan and Fabiano
game is likely to last long well uh
they'll play it to the end uh of course
and by the way in the Maxine Maxine's
last move has shown to me at least that
with this move Rook d8 uh Maxine is
ready just to keep the position
defending the position I thought he
might go a little bit more
ambitiously with his Rook to C8 uh
preparing possible
uh attacks down the SE file instead he
just played rook d8 and said look I've
got a very solid position how are you
Hikaru going to try to pierce my
position as soon as this Knight moves
from D5 he's ready to drop back with his
Bishop in the meanwhile he black is
preemptively uh defending his D6 Pawn
with all of his major pieces very hard
for Hikaru to break through uh this type
of well not going to say Fortress but
this structure one thing that hikaro can
do and we talked about it some time ago
is Advance this Pawn on B4 hoping that
uh he'll be able to play A5 and Knight
B6 and on a very good day pick this Pawn
off of D6 Maurice what do you think
about this position shaping up in
Nakamura Maxim Basher lra great points
you made their Y and interesting to
study this position to see what's the
potential in Black's game it is clear
clear what white is after domination on
the defile control of the D5 Square he
already has and one day picking off that
D6 Pawn also in the move B4 you mention
yes we were you know going down the same
paths great minds think alike so I
decided to throw this into the computer
what what's black going to do what do
you think about this position well the
engine started analyzing and you want to
know the move they came up with Bishop
to H4 it's like what what does that have
to do with anything okay you might get
in a little Rook to C2 big what if I go
for it with B4 and you says all right
you can you can have that we'll trade
now on D5 Rook takes D5 we'll trade on
B4 and we'll play the move Rook to C2
start thinking about this move a little
bit what do you think well I wondered
first and I knew for sure G3 was a
disaster uh I don't want to have this
kind of position to have to face already
grabbed two pawns now getting a third
with the m threats that's just not a
variation to look at so I said all right
fine what about about the move after
Rook to C2 what about
F3 and the engine played Queen B7 what
is that yeah you pinning the Knight but
uh what about just ripping off your Pawn
on D6 that's not a freebie well no
because of a queen sack out of nowhere
like what check sacrificing the queen
and looking to get into this square if
you don't take it well if you do take it
it's all over Rook takes King up and the
other Rook to C1 and mate in seven you
can start throwing stuff at the king to
stop the mate but this mate is a simply
Unstoppable in the long term after this
move you face this check and this nasty
Checkmate oops backing up to this moment
here after Queen B6 check uh you could
just move the king but black is happy
that you allow this position to land on
the board and uh the only way to stop
mate obviously
this move only to see Bishop to E7 land
in your face so clearly white doesn't
have to fall for this spectacular Queen
sacrifice but black has to play with
some bit of energy and focus on the only
weakness in in White's position which is
the F2 Pawn again there variations to
save that off but certainly potential
here for black if white overreaches guys
thank you Maurice boy those tactics
coming out of the blue didn't see any
Queen sacri IES at all but Bishop H4 a
very ambitious move um the uh game
between Fabiana Karana and leavon Rodin
has has progressed as we expect it to a
four uh Rook ending and uh finally
White's uh kingside pieces really do
have uh good cohesion nice to see that
King of8 in anticipation that white is
planning to move his Pawn One Day to the
E6 where Black's King is ready to
blockade the pawn uh before it gets to
E7 okay E5 Rooks C5 and reminding white
wait a minute uh don't push this Pawn
too quickly uh your Pawn on H5 is
hanging so I think I'm caught up with
the play here I would expect white to
play moves like King F2 followed by G4
King F3 slowly creeping his King up the
board black on his side may want to
trade off oops pardon me uh one pair of
Rooks and reduce the position that much
further to a even
game meanwhile we got to move in the nak
moris battle against Maxim
Vash I don't want to call it a last
place battle no we don't but a fight
nonetheless uh Rook D3 to C3
um I think that Hikaru has come to
the conclusion that he's that he's not
going to be able to uh snap this Pawn
off in any fashion that doesn't allow
some kind of counterplay for black so
he's basically said look with this move
Rook C3 I'm going to stop you from
getting any play along the C file and
maybe by trading off this uh Defender uh
keep defender of the D Pawn um down the
line way down the line maybe this Pawn
on D6 will be vulnerable so Rook Rook D3
to C3 a change of direction if you will
yeah does see him like black the white
should have some kind of way to stretch
black thin but it doesn't seem quite
there does it no not at the moment and
I'm I'm still wondering about this whole
line especially now that we haven't seen
that Bishop that was coming to H4
offering black counterplay against F2
why it was or why it is that hikaro uh
declined the opportunity to play B2 B4
again to boldly point out the obvious
something like oh now the queen on B7
does hit E4 doesn't make it that much
easier for us to trade uh I'm looking at
a variation like this gen where there is
uh counter playing in the position if I
try to snap this Pawn well I end
up losing my uh Knight on B5 no I
don't I don't like it no it's all wrong
so that's why we saw the move Rook C3 by
hikaro maybe he because this bishop does
by the way make it annoying uh for white
maybe white has a mind the move Rook D3
trade Rooks on the C file and then take
take over command of the C file it's
weird cuz it looks prettier for white
but I think that's one of the reasons
why people like the snov that even
though it looks pretty for white
sometimes it's hard to actually make
something of it true uh it does look
like white has a very very nice grip on
the D5 square but like you say for those
people who do Play The fov A lot of
times the advantage is Optical and not
real that's right yeah indeed so and and
and Nakamura of course also familiar
with those types of openings himself
okay a few more moves in the uh game
between kwana and the voni King G2 King
E7 Rook
B2 okay I find that move a little bit
curious to my eyes I would have thought
in this particular case that the move
King F3 was a kind of automatic you want
to bring your king in the end game into
the theater get her battle and in this
case it's clearly the center and/ King
side and the idea behind King F3 is a
straightforward as being able to move
your your pawns instead leavon has
played this move Rook
B2
and
um I'm not too sure why make it simple I
don't know why that move uh leavon felt
was a key now as we wait for the players
to make their moves now um let me ask
you you're playing the ultimate moves on
Monday right right so who do you most
want on your team I'm not going to put
you on the spot and say least but I'm
going to say most so if you if you were
a captain you had to pick first so it's
combination of rapid and Blitz is it an
easy choice or would you have to
consider it for a minute well first of
all obviously I wouldn't want rex that
that goes without question I mean you
know Randy's number one first draft and
how can you say say no to Magnus Carlson
I mean come on the guy's world champion
he's world champion classical chest
Blitz and Rapid so what if Magnus was
taking that becomes harder right well
then you go with a guy who's in form
Fabiano get over here right so those
would be my first but draft and second
round draft picks but you got to start
with Randy
gotcha all right so yes starting to get
competitive I do getting in the eye at
the ti like I'm saying and Maxim F he
played Rook the D7 now Maxim known as a
very some of these players are known
more for their Blitz and Rapid skills
and others and I think Maxim and hikaro
both of the players in this game are
ones who are really known for their
rapid and Blitz ABS absolutely they're
going to be a I think pretty pretty high
picks although anyone in the top six of
in this tournament is got to be a top
pick right we're talking about the
All-Star selection is where we're
heading here now uh Maurice you got to
have some thoughts on this I mean if you
were going to have your dream team
where'd you
start well certainly you're gonna take
Fabby I mean come on fa Randy's great
but Fabby I think is a little better
just a little bit uh I find these kind
of team events very fascinating actually
I remember flying back from here in St
Louis to New York to do commentary on
another team event that was Gary
Kasparov playing with one one
businessman and Magnus Carlson playing
with another I think actually was it was
uh B Weinstein was was a partner was one
of the players he's a he's a chess
master very good player and the other
one I want to say is Allan tefler I
believe it was who uh is another CEO and
they were playing Boaz with with one
player it was Carlson and then they
switched and and uh so Allan would play
with kaspar one game and then they
switched partners and the winner both
times was Magnus Carlson and Gary found
it very frustrating to be making deep
moves that weren't followed up by good
responses or consistent responses or
actually I think it was it was more a
question of he expected his opponent to
sort of get into his mindset and Magnus
was more intrigued or or thought it was
more important to get in the mindset of
his opponents so that they felt more
comfortable that they didn't have to
guess at his 2800 moves and Gary found
that very difficult to do so he end up
losing both games despite switching
Partners in that contest so I think
because the players cannot confer with
one another they cannot say well this is
what my idea is you know you guys are
going to have a tough time you make an
you make a move and and and if Rex is on
your team and he goes what the hell is
that about you know he's not gonna be
able to follow it up so you have to be
able to be comfortable and consistent
knowing that your opponent that that
your partner excuse me is the most
important factor here will they be able
to follow up on your moves if you see a
great Queen sacrifice that m in 10 you
probably don't want to play it because
he'll sack the queen and they'll go dude
just hung his Queen and panic so you
really have to know who your partner is
and play consistently to their strength
so it's going to be a fascinating game
to call uh I'm going to have a lot of
fun I'm sure Jen we're going to have a
ball at least have a chance to crack
some jokes about that game guys well
that'll be it'll be a blast and actually
I think Kikar would be one of my top
picks because he's fast and he's
ruthless too even though it's an
exhibition match I know that all the
players will be very competitive because
it is a serious game Randy and Rex are
serious chest players so um we want to
have serious chess and some players will
I think are just a little bit more
competitive than others in those types
of situations I feel like Karo is going
to be like one of my team's going to win
and I'm going to play fast and I'm going
to play the moves that are um the most
like psychologically um tricky for my
opponents right and just one wrinkle to
point out you're absolutely right
there's no uh Consulting during play
however uh the captains uh Randy and Rex
do get an opportunity for two timeouts
where they can confer with their whole
team during a special timeout oh that'll
be fun absolutely and we do and we've
got another official result in so the
game between our singfield Cup champion
Fabiano Carana and Lana Ronan has been
drawn so Fabiano cementing this
absolutely historic event and phenomenal
performance
rating noes congratulations to him uh he
doesn't he doesn't uh uh spoil eight and
a half out of 10 85% against this F it's
unbelievable it's brilliant a brilliant
performance congratulations sincere
congratulations to Fabiano for just a
magnificent event and for entertaining
us so well yeah and good job to you guys
for picking this tournament to watch
because you know you're like ah the
sinkfield cup that's a tournament I'll
get really into and you were in for a
massive treat in fact there were some uh
some tourists in town and one of them
played a little bit of Chess and they
had heard about the St Louis chess club
so they they walked by the club and they
I was I was just EAS dropping as they
asked the desk is there anything going
on this weekend no really W what luck
funny you should ask we've got the world
champion and some of the best players in
the world right downstairs right
upstairs pardon me yeah okay so a draw
agreed I think it was a an intriguing
game a well wellplayed draw some
wrinkles in the opening and uh leavon
never really got his grippers on the
position so I don't think he really had
chances and actually I do believe that
Karana had the better chances in this
game so that leaves us with one game to
play uh hearu Nakamura mvl uh doing
their best to end uh the 2014 Synchro
cup for themselves on a high note that's
right so two two very young players
number one in the respective T countries
Maxine vasar the number one player in
France and then clearly the strongest
French player in Generations actually oh
yes and also very modest yeah yeah we
remember we were talking about um you
know different players and getting
invents to and getting and how important
the top 10 was and he said for example
it also was important to be number one
in your country but he didn't want to
say himself because he was too modest he
was just you know trying to say that
like there are other factors not just
being in the top 10 but also for
instance car Nakamura started getting
some Choice invitations as soon as you
surpass Scot a kamski's rating as uh the
number one player and he's right
understandably because they want some of
that diversity right oh absolutely and
uh he he uh Maxine is coming France has
really made some remarkable strides I'm
going to say in the last 10 years
especially with aan backro Laurent
fresan uh Edward and on the women's side
there are some very strong players as
well right Grandmaster Marie yeah and of
course who you know as well as great
poker star oh that's right she's also
going to be playing in that poker stars
combined chess and poker event and Maxim
Basher lra actually his friends with her
and said that she's probably the
favorite wow because uh you know she's
had she's done so well in various poker
tournaments throughout the years how
cool is that uh by the way we do I do
like this maneuver uh very nice
defensive maneuver uh that Maxine came
up with he played this move Rook d8
which I thought was uh particularly non-
ambitious however we see this move Rook
D7 which set it set up pardon me for
this bishop on d8 I like the fact that
the B Bishop was on a good diagonal but
it really hit at nothing and the idea
here from Max cen's point of view is he
stands ready to bring his Bishop if the
opportunity were to arise and the bishop
would stand absolutely brilliantly on C5
because in that case Not only would the
bishop be protecting that weakness on
the D6 where it would be eyeballing
White's King on that diagonal uh G1
through A7 so I like this move bishop d8
and I think that hakaru is going to have
a hard time proving that he has any type
of an advantage here again a lot of it
just looks good powerful knight on D5
but uh there's nothing really to follow
up not against this is a good defense by
Maxim bashier lra who has impressed Us
in his this tournament with uh defending
some poor positions um pretty well right
incredibly well I mean he's he's playing
the best in the world he spotted Magnus
a pawn and Drew very nicely and leavon
had a overwhelming position when one
just one small slip by leavon and
instantly Max uh held so and the victim
of some horrible preparation by five
horrible for him fantastic for Fabiano I
mean really his only um very poor moment
was that Queen A4 and G3 not the one as
much with with black where you kind of
can't fault him right he ran into it
massively great preparation just
wonderful prep but the one with white
where he was doing fine and just very
strangely collapsed with G3 and yes
that's right against Fabiano but that
was while that magic was going through
the air Fabiano's on this unbel
believable win streak right just say
pixie dust and of course it is tiring to
play uh 10 games in 11 days so you know
these players are very young so that in
some ways it benefits and hurts
everybody equally but it it can I think
uh slightly lower the quality of the
play towards certain inflection points
in the tournament don't you think yeah
well end yeah yeah especially at the end
you do feel the fatigue of having your
brain working at a RPMs uh for hours and
hours in a row that's right but we have
been gifted with some absolutely
fabulous chass I just uh so many
instructive games so many beautiful
games and I really think there's been a
lot of games where you can teach teach
students you know that's a great thing
about Chess that even a game played by
the best players in the world there's a
lesson that you can grab from it that
can be useful for a player who's just
starting out without question and that's
why I really like the old classical
World Championship
matches U the alakin and the bod vinck
and the Kappa Blancas is because I felt
that I was there and I played over those
games and I felt that I really learned a
lot just by playing through world
championship match games and we do have
our guests uh getting set up in the
studio here yeah exactly and don't
forget that when that Nakamura Maxim
bashra game end the clock starts and 30
minutes after that game is over our
press conference will will begin
approximately 30 minutes might be 31 or
32 but approximately a half hour after
that game ends you're going to want to
tune in for that press conference over
at lesters and now we have leavon
aronian in the studio with Maurice
Ashley and leavon a national hero in
Armenia we love to have him here in St
Louis and I'm curious about his
Impressions on the singfield cup he's
with Maurice to talk about about that
thanks Jen I'm with grandmas leavon
aronian leavon the number three player
in the world now uh this tournament
certainly was not your best you came in
and you said first thing you said to me
I'm happy this horror has finished uh
please share your thoughts on this
tournament
yeah I mean there's not much to share I
just didn't didn't play any any good
games at all I mean just uh many
mistakes so it was a disastrous
tournament why do you think that is
normally you your fine play we we love
enjoying your fine play that's made you
for so long the number two ranked player
in the world um it's I mean it's
difficult to say I I I know the reasons
I mean I can guess the reasons why I'm
playing badly but uh I don't want to
share them not want to make excuses I
understand uh today's game against
Carana you played for something
ambitious in the opening with the move
King F1 but it seemed to fizzle out
fairly quickly in the middle game at
least going to an end game where you
didn't have much I think I was worse
because uh H4 was a terrible move I mean
it just doesn't make any sense and of
course I should have continued with F4
the most natural way King F2 E4 Bishop
E3 you know how they do it the good
guys so but instead said I just thought
okay let's play H5 and then see and I
realized
that I realized that I don't know what
to do so I didn't see any good plan to
contact B5 B4 idea and I think uh at
some point I was in trouble I had this
feeling uh so when you play the move
Bishop to H3 did you think he had a move
Bishop D1 did you oh I was
terrified I thought well I've done it
again you know cuz cuz this is a move
I've wondered well well the computer
says you have a Fighting Chance in that
position but Bishop D1 did look
attractive like recirculating the bishop
and your pieces look a little odd yeah
because I can't really uh get my Rook
into some safe place so that was if we
may uh bring that up because you use the
mouse and goes to the position after
Bishop H3 uh 22 Yeah so Bishop so Bishop
D1 to to this Square looked very strong
well I thought Rook D5 I'm slightly
worse that's what I thought right the
engines agree you were you were you
surprised he didn't play that movie he
instead traded and and kept kept
Advantage within bounds because you were
able to equalized pretty quickly after
that no I wasn't really surprised you
know I mean it's not easy to play when
you have just won the tournament I mean
couple of days so I guess that's why uh
Fabiano wasn't playing as good as uh he
did in the first seven rounds right
that's a difficulty isn't it after you
win a tournament the sort of just the
whole pressure is gone from you and it's
hard to really stay motivated to play
that last round yeah the last couple of
rounds in this Cas yes yes so it
happened to me it happened to many
people what does the Future Hope for you
this tournament is now passed what's
your next event well I'll I'll try to
have some kind of Rehabilitation in the
bilb tournament it's it's going to be
the Grand Slam again
and after that I'll just uh sit and uh
figure out what do I have to do not to
play so badly W we' we've seen you play
much better we sure you'll be back one
last question what is your feeling about
this tournament the singfield cup now
you've been here two years in a row as
an addition to the the tournament
circuit well it's a wonderfully
organized tournament and I mean
everybody's so friendly and everybody is
doing so many good things for the
players you know uh unfortunately in my
case the players are not really giving
back well lean you've treated us to a
lot of wonderful games we sure you will
take the lessons from this competition
and and be back to your top 2800 self
thank you very much Grand Master leavon
aronian one of the most likable guys in
chess we wish him well in his future
games and I'm sure we'll see him back
here can we get a commitment you going
be back for the same C next year if they
ask you uh well if I'm invited be happy
to you heard it here folks so we got
Magnus on record and leavon on record
the singfield cup one of the great
Traditions or New Traditions on the
World Tournament circuit back to you
guys and uh while we still have le on
the air um yaser San wants to challenge
you to bug house oh yeah no oh sorry so
I've been trash talking uh leavon as you
can well imagine and it's my considered
opinion that if I were to have Hikaru
Nakamura as my Bug House partner and you
were to have man and form uh Fabiano
Carana as your partner not only could
you guys compete that you might get a
draw out of
10 that's the first time I've ever heard
yaser trash oh no it's not the first
time I've heard it well like that down
the challenge I've played with uh
Fabiano as a partner and I I have lost
against very weaked position so Fabiano
is is much better in chess significantly
better in chess than he is in black
house but if I if I get uh AR Arian as
my partner Arian you're you're yes and
then we'll your lady yes she's like 2200
maybe 2300 player yes but she loves to
play back house as much as I do so
that's your secret weapon yes and you
think you'll be Nakamura and yasan for
sure for
sure well that's a battle we all want to
see we're going to have some fun on the
off days guys this is going to be a lot
of fun here at St Louis where you could
throw a rock and hit a grandmas I mean
it's absolutely incredible but please
don't do that don't do that but I don't
want to take leavon away from his task
because his next task will be his Fisher
uh 960 matchup so okay he can train for
that but we can train with bug house too
yeah absolutely a little little bug
house I want to see this match yeah oh
me three me3 and don't worry we'll let
you know how it went photos will
certainly be had for sure for sure I
want sign score sheets in
fact uh we do have some moves by the way
uh between uh Hikaru and uh mvl let's
just go back and see what has transpired
we got to this position Rook C3 uh White
just challenged for the control of the C
file Rook D7 Rook D1 D3 and the bishop
came back to d8 and this was a moment
that I think uh basically hikaro said
it's now or never I've got a strike here
he traded Rooks Queen takes Rook to C3
and after the queen dropped back well
check this out there is a fork on the C7
square and Hikaru went for it but I'm
just wondering is this going to work out
because remember this queen on e4 pardon
me the queen on E8 does hit the E4
Square so if we do go for this trade
trade I'm taking with the Knight maybe
I'm doing it wrong there's a queen takes
E4 and check this out maybe some kind of
forks in the position
no I can escape this Fork by checking
down on E1 so some still some
interesting tactics in this game
absolutely our Champions with us yes we'
got our sinkfield Cup champion Fabiano
Carana who was apparently mobbed on his
way down here but now he's with Maurice
Ashley I'm sure Maurice won't mention
what leavon said no of course we he will
well it's good to be the king and we
have with us the king of the singfield
cup congratul Fabi Carana on an
excellent performance thank you has it
sunk in yet you've had the greatest
tournament performance by rating in
history can you can you put that into
context for us um yeah I'm very happy
about the entire tournament uh let's say
except for um rounds eight and N I'd
rather forget about round nine very
quickly um but in any case yeah I'm yeah
I'm very very pleased with my
performance well you could have had nine
and and a half out of 10 how could you
disappoint us so well of course uh such
a performance is epic to go down
alongside all the great performances in
history tell us about today's game it
seemed like a much more solid Affair um
yeah from the opening okay he tried a
new idea with CD4 and King F1 but we had
checked it a while back I I thought
Black's position should be more or less
maybe slightly worse but more or less
solid okay I'm just a bit behind in
development but uh on the other hand
it's King takes some time to to get to
safety um and okay I thought that I
should be able to defend this position
um but at some point I was just very
comfortable uh and I even started to get
slightly better I avoided a repetition
probably I was a bit too ambitious and
at the end I was already worried that I
was getting slightly worse so I decided
to offer a draw as soon as I could and
right at move 30 which is within the
rules he was probably also not feeling
like playing so much and uh accepted
although I think he could probably put
his King on G4 and try to play on it's a
bit better for it but it should be a
drill was it hard for you to play the
last few rounds uh you had the whole
thing sewn up two rounds to spare that's
not something that you expect to see
happen in in the world class play I'm
not sure it's ever happened to you uh
two rounds left and it's over was it
difficult to play those games it's
definitely never happened to me oh well
it has happened in the sense that it's
over but over for me um but I tried to
play
normally uh in my last couple of games
yeah yesterday was a big disappointment
uh it was a very simple win and I I
didn't really see much which was u a
problem uh I'm not sure why again I I
wasn't sure yesterday and I'm still not
sure what happened but um yeah okay
today I think I played more or less
normally a bit inaccurately at some
point but I think it was a more or less
balanced game you as mentioned you were
mobbed coming downstairs uh America
loves you you were born here in America
uh lived abro for some time is there a
rumor out here that you might think
about coming back to the US and
representing the United States um well
so far it's uh just rumors um but uh
yeah I'd rather not say too much about
that uh you have been a top player for
quite some time I mean you were just
turned number three in the world you
were number three in the world walking
in you're now number two in the world
but play it seems now that your stat has
grown tremendously there's discussion
maybe of you're even having a match
against Magnus
Carlson numbers one and two 23 years old
22 years old what do you think about the
the hype of course you know people like
us suggest things like that uh yeah okay
it's normal that there's going to be a
lot of hype after um after this result
but I still have to follow it up with
good results um and maybe I'll get a
match in the future but uh it's still a
long way ahead and uh nothing's
nothing's for certain right now so okay
if I keep on playing like this then then
my rating will go up to whatever my
whatever my performance is but I don't
expect that at all um but I'd like to
just keep on playing normal chess pretty
solidly and uh um and I don't expect
results like this but I'll try to to
keep my level and um and in terms of the
world championship cycle I'll try to get
as far as I can normal chess pretty
level pretty decent those are not the
words we use to describe you in this
broadcast do you have your eye on being
number one in the world I mean the world
championship cyle is one thing but the
number one rating probably means a bit
more what do you think about uh becoming
number one what's your goal um yeah for
the moment um I Magnus has about 2870 or
well I'm not sure maybe a bit less now
but uh I've never actually even dreamed
of a rating like that and I was always
wondering uh how he could manage to to
keep it and somehow keep on increasing
it um so those aren't my thoughts at the
right now I mean I usually don't have
performances over
2850 um but or
2950 or 3,000 that's yeah that's the
first for me um
but yeah okay I'll try I mean I think
that in individual games I can I'm fully
capable of beating him um at the moment
he has a small plus I think plus one in
our encounters but I can also beat him
as I've shown um so I think that it's
possible to compete against him well
we're looking forward to that match up
for sure there's a question I've been
forced to ask my arm has been Twisted to
ask this the question is are you single
uh I am uh oh ladies ladies okay I asked
the question and put it out there uh
there definitely some interested folks
uh
one final comment the singfield Cup
itself St Louis the organization what's
your opinion on that um I really enjoyed
this tournament I think in terms of
organization it's definitely one of the
one of the best I've ever played and uh
also in terms of well not just for the
players but also for the spectators
which is maybe even more important uh
and I think you guys did a great job
with your commentary um I didn't have so
much of a chance to to look at all the
broadcasts uh I mean the recorded ones
but uh I had looked at a few and uh yeah
I think that you you guys did a great
job and Rex also did an amazing job with
the tournament uh everything was at the
highest level and I think um we showed
it in terms of our play we were all
fighting and showing interesting chess
which is the most important thing well
thanks very much for the compliment with
play like yours you make our job very
very easy I you know what I I apologize
I said the last question but one more
question if reinvites would you be back
to the singfield cup sure just a little
muted sure always muted in responses I'm
sure they'll be inviting you back once
again congratulations on fantastic
performance uh as a person who's seen a
lot of Chess and read a lot of Chess
history to be able to witness your
performance live has been a real treat
thank you
congratulations guys our tournament
champion one fabulous faban Carana the
Victor at the singfield cup guys our
deepest congratulations Faby you really
entertained us and uh delighted us with
your performance and we wish you the
best of success I mean it was really
something special just about 3100
performance rating here wow off the
charts W off the charts uh our final
game it does look like it's heading
towards a draw um I was surprised it
wasn't a draw in with this little uh
this little move you had expected a
repetition as did I we got to this
position and uh hikara went for forcing
line where we saw a lot of Trades a lot
of pieces coming off the boards right
here after this move Queen C6 I believe
was played yes indeed Queen C6 was
played I expected I think as did Eugen
Queen takes D6 setting up for a knight
uh Fork a royal Fork however instead of
taking the queen and dropping a pawn
oops pardon me instead of taking the
queen and dropping the pawn I mvl could
reach into his own bag of tricks and
force a Perpetual check yeah this is how
I expected it to end repetition but we
didn't see Hikaru play Queen takes D6
instead we saw Hikaru capture oops I beg
your pardon we saw hikaro capture the
bishop with check and after Pawn takes
where in a dead even Queen and pawn
ending and um well White's Queen on A3
which I kind of hinted at a long long
time ago it's not really in the game and
uh this again we might see a similar
repetition for example in case of B4 we
could see again this little Perpetual
check that's a standard Motif in so many
positions of Perpetual check we've seen
a lot of r Che in this thrilling
tournament and we're going to take a
quick break to uh look at some of the
exhibitions over at the World Chess Hall
of Fame and then we're going to wrap up
our 2014 singfield cup coverage with
this final game underway um followed by
the press conference so stay tuned and
we'll be back for the finale of this
[Music]
event
this project is called The Burning
boards and it's a it's a performance
piece well what inspired me you know
starting with a quote from Martin heiger
which says the possible ranks higher
than the
actual when two people's play they
interpret what other one might be
thinking and they anticipate the
possible and there's infinite amount of
uh possibilities happening and then when
they make a move it flattens out out
into one choice and a myriad of
possibilities becomes one actual
decision this event has been performed
only twice before uh the first time at
the Whit Whitney Museum of Art in New
York City as part of their banial and
then at the Orange County Museum in
Southern
California when the performance begins
they start to melt at different speeds
based on things like the wind the air
condition conditioning people's
breathing you know the formation on the
board and the the two players have to
collaborate to remember what pieces are
which because it's very possible that
your queen might melt shorter than a
rook and you have to remember which one
it is and in that way a conflict could
also result in
collaboration this piece was so perfect
to be here in the middle of one of the
greatest chess communities in in the
country the chess community that seen
come together time and again uh here at
the chess club in in St Louis I was
surprised by how much the grand Masters
seem to like it I don't think that this
is going to be turned into a
professional sport but yeah I really
enjoyed
[Music]
it a memorable life a glimpse into the
complex mind of Bobby fer
[Music]
explores a memorable life a glimpse into
the complex mind of Bobby fiser explores
the life and career of one of the
greatest chess players of all time the
exhibition includes artifacts from the
collection of the World Chess Hall of
Fame and Loans from the Fisher library
of Dr Genie and Rex singfield many of
which have never been exhibited
spotlighting historic moments throughout
Fisher's story career the show includes
displays dedicated to his early
victories and studies with Jack Collins
the publication of my6 memorable games
and the 1972 World Chess Championship
newly added to the exhibition are videos
of several famous television appearances
by Bobby fiser including his 1958
appearance on I've got a secret and 1972
appearances on 60 Minutes and The
Tonight Show the exhibition will be in
view at the World Chess Hall of Fame
through June
[Music]
2015 the World Chess Hall of fame's
exhibition cun Kyo pieces and
performances displays the artwork of two
artists who use chess as a medium to
create Innovative performance art
including artist Glenn Kino's learn to
win or youu will take losing for granted
a Monumental chessboard with pieces made
of Bron casts of the artist's own hands
as well as his one-hour paintings which
depict famous players the exhibition
shows how chess inspires
[Music]
artists I'm hiar nakur you're watching
the singfield Cup live in St
Lewis hey welcome back to the tail end
of our coverage here of the 2014 S field
cup because it looks like this game
there's a lot of ways for it to head
towards a draw right we're going to wrap
this game up as a draw and get ready for
our press conference uh the last few
moves by the way I'm just a little bit
worried that
Hikaru might be belowing it a little bit
I had expected him to play B2 B4 and
after B4 again that same Perpetual
checking Motif that is so common uh in
Queen endings would occur instead he
played this move G2 G3 and I thought
that mvl was going to pounce and play
check King up up and queen
D2 uh covering these two pawns on A5 and
D6 while stopping white from playing B4
and I thought that marginally speaking
slightly better for
mvl instead we saw mvl play King F7 and
I think uh there are several ways now
once more for white to go ahead and make
a
draw so this is a good time to reflect
on this tournament which we've been
doing a lot over the last couple days uh
it's been such a great pleasure to do
this and to work with uh both the crews
at Spectrum Studios and fat Chim Studios
absolutely all the all the people here
just been a joy to work with and the
staff and the staff Absol chess club or
the World Chess Hall of Fame everybody
is on double duty here right like people
aren't taking vacation days for Labor
Day and a shout out to all the good
people at Lester too for providing such
wonderful food and uh it's just been a
it's just been a pleasure just a
pleasure to work with you Jen and with
Maurice most especially um you my
favorite commentators you
guys my favorites oh love yeah there's
always a love fest going on here in St
Louis I tell you the big event for me
the millionaire chess open that's coming
up in October boy when you're in St
Louis you realize you have some really
big shoes to fill it's like whoa this is
how a chess tournament ought to be every
single time out this is what we we love
to to see in the United States these
kinds of events super high quality
well-run the staff is is friendly and
fantastic any need you have is
immediately catered to best they can uh
of course the the studios who put this
on fat chimp will be joining us for the
millionaire chess over open just just
hanging out with the crew makes you feel
good uh that it's just such a great
place to be St Louis you talk about the
food and the hotel the
chase everyone uh Joy Bray who refuses
to come on camera and take any credit
for anything but without her nothing
happens she's a fantastic leader Tony
Rich of course who doesn't mind a camera
by the way but but uh great guy it just
goes down the list the list goes on and
on uh the amazing staff they have here
and the quality uh and attention they
put in to making all their events
fantastic indeed and after five five or
six years just the community coming
around you know always seeing mayor SLE
coming to the tournaments even tweeting
at us Gary Kasparov tweeting at us just
these these Legends and these these
Stars it's it's really awesome uh chess
24 you know their platform and also all
of their daily articles right I mean of
course all of the major websites uh you
know posted lots of fascinating stuff um
grandmas Alejandra Ramirez and Ben fold
veru niobe and Ian Rogers in addition to
their commentary here offering some
annotations which appear on chess 20
chess chess space in particular and the
St Louis chess club website so after the
tournament you can still go back and in
addition to rewatching our commentary
learn even more about the game and all
those nice memories but uh truthfully
Jen uh after all of this wonderful love
Fest and this uh thank you sharing bad
bad no no no I come to the chess club
today and there's this little boy with
his father Chris and Stevie and there's
Stevie with his eyes as bigest flying
saucers as he's looking at his chess
Heroes and just uh you realize you're
doing it for the next generation and
they're so so happy to see everybody
here and and again another shout out to
the players because I really want to say
this and emphasize it so very much their
cooperation their willingness to go to
lers World Chess Hall of Fame to sit
down with Maurice even after most
difficult defeat and to share their
thoughts that's really special and so
thank you very very much to all of the
singfield Cup players I great
sportsmanship I know Magus Carlson has
so many fans and as I understand today's
game afterwards he was mobbed and he was
very patient and gracious and you know
signing autographs for all his and even
selfies I've seen him in a number of
selfies everybody wants a selfie with
magnet that's nice I like it I like it
so yeah it's it's it's been absolutely
wonderful and uh as this a queen end
game wraps up it's yeah just a great
opportunity to again remind you Monday
ultimate move ulate move you will get
another chance to see your favorite
players in the world battling and this
time a little bit more a little less
serious right and and I'm looking
forward to that press conference too
feuring all six 2014 te St fod cup
competitors we've got a mix of rapid and
Blitz Games and they're going to involve
Rex singfield the founder and president
of the chess club and Randy singfield
the founder of spectrum Studios and
they're going to face off against the
competition now how are we going to get
Dr Genie singfield In the Mix maybe
another year but she's she she's been
watching a few of these broadcast and
she knows knows a thing or two about the
chess game as well oh yes she do oh yes
she does oh yes and of course it's in
celebration of Rex's 70th birthday so a
shout out to Rex respect that's 70
doesn't seem old at all when you see
that interview with 84y old Harry Benson
I mean who seems to be enjoying life
good he seemed super youthful that was
actually pretty inspiring not only that
the things he was saying were so
interesting but that he's going strong
yeah what an eventful life he must have
led remarkable The Beatles Joe name with
Bobby Fisher wow and that was his
favorite yeah there you go and again a
reminder our press conference as well so
not just ultimate moves on Monday but
also in 30 minutes we've got a live
press conference with all the players so
all the players in the press conference
and all the players on Monday so
following the game 30 minutes later will
be the following the completion of this
uh exactly so there's some time to get
set up and get the players over there
but hopefully you're here in person if
not it will be live streamed as
well all right Jen well thank so any any
juice left in this position no no not
really I'm kind of expecting that maybe
we'll see something like a queen F3
check a king E7 type of move and maybe
something like B2 B3 but in these
endings where pawns are even for both
sides Queen endings are notor
notoriously drawn so no juice here no
juice here so hikaro Nakamura
disappointing result here in the
singfield cup but a little ray of light
yesterday when he saved this what seemed
like an unsavable position as he put it
himself he got a break and he didn't get
very many breaks in this tournament when
I think about it you have to go back to
round three where he had vessel and
topof there without a special sacrifice
move that uh he Caro his Miss Bishop
takes F2 check thereafter everything
went South I mean so it's hard to say
but round three seemed to be the turning
point for America's number one and of
course he's a inspiration for American
kids all over all over the country
because um you know he's really shown
that even without you know all that
frequent travel to Europe he was able to
become an elite player of course he
traveled a lot but he wasn't right there
in the B of things remember he was
developing it was before the St Louis
chess club absolutely absolutely so he
he overcame a lot to to reach his
exalted status and as he said he feels
like he needs 2014 to end maybe he just
needs the new school year to to begin uh
Maurice um final thoughts on this
tournament as we uh prepare to uh to
close well I am reminded of the
Fantastic play of Fabiano caran
in this tournament you asked you asked
Gary Kasparov what his favorite moment
is and I think he didn't didn't get what
you you said or didn't hear the question
quite accurately so he answered
something else but you talked about best
game by Fabby and my favorite memory is
Bishop takes on E6 that sacrifice I'd
like to just quickly go over that here
this moment in the game if you haven't
seen it you better hurry up and check
this out when the move Rook to E3 was
played and it was a setup because the
move Knight C6 allowed this fantastic
shot Bishop takes on E6 Pawn takes Rook
check the king moved and Bam the queen
was in and after this Rook move Queen
over attacking the rook and it was this
sweet move E6 that we all loved
sacrificing this Rook but just leaving
this position uh in tatters this Pawn
owning the board and after Bishop back
then the move Queen H5 check and all
kinds of mating ideas present Bishop
takes G7 and his opponent resigned this
was such a thrilling moment for us guys
we watched it unfold uh he played so
many great games to I remember having a
discussion with with Rex singfield and
he said well you know to have a great
performance you've got to play well and
have some luck and I disagreed
vehemently I said this guy was not lucky
he was so well prepared and Kasparov
himself when he came on agreed he said
there was not luck in those first seven
rounds he just played like a beast to be
able to sit back and watch such a per
performance it reminds me of guys like
Michael Jordan when you saw him against
the Portland Trailblazers hitting shot
after shot at the shot three after three
and when he's running down the court and
he's going I don't know I'm just doing
it that's what you saw in Fabby in this
tournament just an epic performance a
thrill to be able to sit and watch that
greatness happen right before our very
eyes watch the young man grow and expand
into the international Superstar status
that he absolutely deserves it has been
a thrilled to be here working with you
guys and it looks like it just keeps
getting better guys the more we hang out
the better it gets just enjoying these
these times here I'm sad to to see it in
well it's not over yet we still have
some work to do but just wonderful to be
a part of the magic that is here in St
Louis thank you Maurice uh for me
obviously it was all Fabby Fabby Fabby
what a story he has made for us and I
agree that game toppel off Bishop e six
was nice but no no no no no no the
moment of the tournament for uh the
fabulous one had to be when he was black
against world champion number one Magnus
Carlson the world champion sacrificed
his Bishop on F7 and said I'm going to
take you down fa Fabby said no I think
my position's really good he accepted
the sacrifice of the world champion
refuted the attack took over the
initiative and won with a very deaft but
beautiful queen Retreat uh to wrap up
that game and to me to just take the
world Champion's best punch and roll
with the punches and then win that game
nah that was one for the
ages indeed I mean there's so many games
to choose from because he won
soam right I mean there's that uh that
strategic Masterpiece against leavon
aronian where I mean he also had some
great preparation but wasn't like oh my
preparation wins me the game
spectacularly it was just and then
setting up for that sacrifice of the two
pawns and keeping Leon's King under
constant harassment brilliant great
stuff so many Beautiful Moments and um
we do believe this game will end in a
draw between Nakamura and Maxim basier
the gra so we are going to take our
break and um we are going to be back
yaser Saran is going to be in the
battlefield but Grandmaster morce Ashley
Grand Mr Alejandra Ramirez and uh Teran
jaer we are going to be back to cover
the ultimate moves right and in about 30
minutes or whenever this game ends maybe
it's going to be more like 45 minutes
well with V4 being played perhaps even
sooner we are going to have our press
conference so stay tuned for that tune
in on Monday and thank you everyone for
just tuning in from all over the world
for this event the 2014 singfield cup a
tournament that will no doubt go down in
history as one of the most exciting and
the greatest tournament performance
[Music]
ever
for
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
he
e
[Music]
for
get
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
e
d
[Music]
all
for
[Music]
oh
for
[Music]
h
hello everyone and welcome to the press
conference uh wrapping up the 2014
singfield cup I'm Tony Rich the
executive director of the chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis just a
couple of quick housekeeping items for
you um please event you know and make
sure that the uh everybody has an
opportunity to ask questions also if you
could um please stand when you have a
question I'll come over and hold the mic
near you and if you could uh state your
name and who you're reporting with and
then follow up with who your question is
aimed toward and what the question is
all right so let's kick things off um
I'm ready for our first
question not all at
once all right of course my question is
for Magnus um you had a not a best
tournament I guess H what are you going
to do now to get back on the horse are
you going to train more or uh do you
need some time off of
Chess oh I'm from TV2 Norway and my name
is
k um I don't know um I think um the
tournament wasn't that bad um there were
um few details in in a few of the games
that prevented me from having a pretty
solid tournament so I think there's not
um that much that is wrong um I just
need to
be a little better prepared a little
sharper at the critical moments the next
time and
um hopefully someone won't make uh plus
seven
Cu uh regardless of what form I'm in
it's going to be hard to compete with
that okay next question
hello my name is Ben Simon with the
chess club in Scholastic Center of St
Louis my question is for Fabby um since
you left the United States about a
decade ago St Louis has really emerged
as a St Louis or as a chess Hub what do
you think the chess culture of the
United States is these days has it
changed if so how or maybe even not
um okay well after Fisher became world
champion there was a huge boom in the
United States but yeah after that it
died died out a bit and uh I think that
recently we're seeing a bit of a an
increase in interest in the United
States in chess uh and I think that's
great uh and uh I hope that it continues
that uh that more top events are are
organized
uh and okay we just have to to thank Rex
for for uh starting this new wave of
interest uh in the United
States and I have a follow-up question
that for hakaru having played in the
United States quite a bit uh open events
private tournaments major events like
these uh what's your experience been
like especially over the the past few
years more recently on chess in the
United States stage um well well for
stars I have a lot of good memories this
uh this tournament excluded um
unfortunately quite U wasn't the best
event I've ever had but um again I think
you know really it's due in large part
to Rex and jie singfield without their
contributions I don't think any of this
would have been possible um nevertheless
uh I think it's great um that it's gone
beyond that in a sense I mean now you
have um you have a lot of very strong
players like Wesley so or um lawang leam
for example who are both at Webster
University so I think um it really
started with Rex and Genie but now it's
it's gone beyond that and I think it's
great that there's such interest in
chess here in St Louis and um I mean for
all the people who come out uh it's it's
really great because I know growing up
um there were very few strong
tournaments here in America and I would
always have to go to Europe to play so
um again I think it's it's just great to
see what's happening here and hopefully
uh it only continues for
here okay next
question I'm diim
shabaz I run uh the chest drum website
my question is directed to both hakaru
and Fabiano remember years
ago I saw both of you playing in
tournaments um as a
junior uh and this question is is simply
did you ever imagine that you would be
pretty much at the top of the Chess
World I'll answer it first cuz I'm I'm
not at the top of the Chess
World that's not not quite the right way
of putting it
um I mean I I think uh I never could
have imagined there would be top level
events here in America like I said
before I mean from the time I was
probably about 13 14 years old I was
always going to Europe to play these
events and you know it's great that the
tournament are here in app that again
the sacrific my parents made um paying
for all these trips to Europe um is uh
well I mean it it speaks for itself the
sacrific they made and so to have the
opportunities to come back to America
and play in top Lev events um it's it's
just a really good feeling cuz certainly
growing up I didn't have these
opportunities so I'm really happy that
there are these opportunities now and
Pano um yeah when I was a kid I didn't
imagine that I
would that I would play chess
professionally I mean I always loved
chess but uh when I was a kid it was
just a hobby I would after school I
would go and play uh in a marshall chess
club and I would play game 30s uh and I
didn't think it would uh I mean I
thought I would just have
a that at some point I would move away
from chess that I would uh keep going to
school but uh okay it worked out this
way and I'm very happy about it but uh I
don't yeah I didn't really have those
thoughts when I was when I was a kid all
right and we have another question here
hello Yer San for the St Louis chess
club and Scholastic Center this uh
question is really directed at vesselin
vesselin um you uh you started the
tournament poorly 0 and two and you're
the veteran in the field at 38 years old
and I'm looking around at the podium and
everything everybody's so much younger
than you could you sorry sorry there you
have it uh could you explain why chess
is such a young man's game today and
we're seeing uh this
Rise um okay thank you for reminding me
my age but actually I'm
39 uh you know you know actually I don't
mind retiring but for the reason for the
moment I don't see a reason you know and
it's very simple it's just about uh
memory I guess it's a little bit of
motivation and it's memory uh
okay the way chess has developed in the
last years it's more about more more
about new computer lines and all this
stuff so um what we do basically many
times before the game is to memorize
long lines and in that of course we
cannot compete with youngers youngsters
and then of course uh in games that last
long obviously uh youngsters they kind
of recover much easier and quicker and
that's it I guess and it's a little bit
also
motivation but but okay again if you
remember if you know cooi even when he
was 80 he was still very motivated so
it's very
personal okay our next
question hi I'm Mike Klein with
chess.com um I'd like to ask a question
of Fabiano's five competitors if you
could sum up his performance using a
single word so maybe we could
start start over with hiar when work
I'll use I'll say fantastic one to put
it in Italian you know you know what I
mean no it's like really memorable I
mean it will stay in the history I
guess
depressing
[Applause]
well I will say
w again
sorry
ruthless oh
surprising maybe the winner himself I
have to say thanks to the one
I was also I was also surprised so yeah
I'd say surprising as
well Leon we had a question submitted
for you also uh will you speak about
your recent surgery and how that may
have impacted your play here in St Louis
uh didn't impact anything I just played
terribly don't really have any excuses
and I don't want to come up with
any okay next
question
Mr
Nakamura um a lot of Norwegian viewers
were wondering why you were wearing a
New York Red Bulls jersey with the
number 32 one of these days um okay well
Red Bull happens to be one of my main
sponsors
um uh it's more about the can as opposed
to a shirt but nevertheless I felt like
wearing it um that being said I've now
have a 0 and3 record with it I've lost
twice to Magnus and I lost to I think it
was Bessel in here so I don't think
you'll be seeing uh much more of that
shirt for
a we'll have to find you a new
football okay next
question from the
audience okay I'll try oh hang on I'll
try one of these that we also had
submitted uh this one's for vessel and
too the singfield cup is good proof that
a youth movement is happening in chess
but you are looking stronger than ever
at 39 can you speak a little bit about
the advantages of experience uh to
follow up on yaser's question and the
advantages of um just kind of the the
knowledge that you've built up over the
years you've played
chess oh
it's B Bas main advantages I'm just very
relaxed and not really I don't
know don't really play so much about
result and don't don't try to prove
anything just in Joy really and of
course there but basically there are
many more
disadvantages thank you next question
please
Ben hi Ben Simon with the chess club
once again um Magnus out of respect for
your tournament play this go around uh a
lot of people have been forgoing this
question but following Gary kasparov's
footsteps if the Fay title match doesn't
come together for you will you retain
your title in your mind as the real
classical world
champion uh that's a good question but
not one that I can answer
unfortunately okay uh this next question
was submitted for Fabiano your seven win
win streak really set the Chess World on
Fire uh would you describe uh how the
ALS Ice Bucket Challenge you did just
before uh which now has 20,000 hits on
YouTube by the way uh may have impacted
that start and will you try it
again um I hope that that wasn't the
reason why I played so well um otherwise
everyone will start doing it and uh yeah
then I'm not sure what will happen um
but okay it was just be I mean I was
just enjoying everything when I came to
St Louis uh and I was feeling good and I
think the fact that I did that uh was uh
was a reflection on on the the fact that
I that I felt uh was just feeling good
and ready to
play um I don't think it had a direct
impact on my play
though okay another
question a let's do
it Danny wrench with chess.com this
question is from Maxim I was wondering
how you felt about your
performance uh maybe for the first time
I guess no one's ever played in
tournament this strong before but for
you playing in a a tournament of this
caliber having two games against all of
these peers that are were higher rated
than you coming into the event how you
feel about your performance and what you
will take back to the drawing board as
far as your preparation and as far as
other things you may not have executed
well over the board
thanks well first of all I hope I
learned a lot because it was not the
first time I played in a
tournament um a very strong tournament
but it was a definitely the first time
that I played 10 games in a world
against these guys and so I hope I
learned a lot but I'm not satisfied with
my play in general especially in the
second half I was playing a bit flowy a
bit I was lacking some that well I will
be able to to this club but maybe later
after I take some time to reflect on on
the event but I was very happy to play
here of
course okay this next question is for
Hikaru Nakamura can you explain or or
describe what your thoughts are on the
current um Fay World Championship cycle
including the Grand Prix events uh
candidates turn uh matches um and the
General State of Chess within
fed okay that's a interesting question
um I think uh you know at the moment the
system is what it is really there's
nothing you can do about that and if
there isn't a major alternative we're
unfortunately stuck with the system as
it currently stands and beyond that I I
think we just have to see what happens
really okay next
question hi hi um the question is for
Magnus Magnus um last year you were here
in St Louis and then a month later you
became the world champion uh For Better
or Worse how have things changed since
then oh well I played a lot worse this
year that's one thing that's uh that's
changed
um I don't know I I haven't changed too
much as uh as person so I
think um many things are about about the
same and uh well the the tournament was
um a little bit bigger a little bit
stronger than than last year uh which
was already a great tournament and um
hopefully when I come back um if I come
back if there is a tournament next year
uh next year uh the tournament will be
um will be even stronger and maybe I'll
even play a bit little bit better who
knows this next question is for Fabiano
Fabiano can obviously you were in great
form for this event and I'm sure that
there was a lot of preparation before
you even arrived in St Louis can you
speak a little bit to what your uh
training regimen is like including uh
the the Practical aspects of studying
chess but in addition to that the other
things that you do to get ready for a
big
event um well before this event I didn't
do much um I didn't have a chance to do
much preparation because I played the
Olympiad and there wasn't a big break in
between um and when I came here I needed
a few days to get acclimated I wasn't
really working on chess I was just
trying
to to feel physically at in top shape um
although before this event I got a bit
sick uh so I wasn't probably in the best
shape that I could have been
um but in any case I felt pretty well
prepared to play uh it's more about more
about the psychological feeling you have
than than the direct preparation because
sometimes sometimes you'll be have a lot
of time to to prepare uh for a
tournament and sometimes you just don't
have much time you can't really control
those things but it's important in any
case to to be ready to play and to fight
uh and in this case I was
thank you next question from the
audience right up
here uh for Fabiano do you feel
confident that you've kind of jumped up
a level are you seeing things more
clearly uh kind of Beyond just being in
this result is kind of more than being
in good form this is you know Quantum
Leap for anyone but how do you feel
about where this place is you going
forward
um of course this this result is very
well it's my best uh best result I've
ever had uh and uh but I mean okay you
know we shouldn't draw too many
conclusions from it I still have to to
maintain my level of play uh it's
possible to play very well in one
tournament and then after that
to to start playing much worse I hope
that well I mean I don't expect to to
make plus seven in in every event but I
hope that I can keep on playing normally
trying to fight for top places and uh
and okay the main thing is that I
haven't been making as many mistakes I
haven't changed uh drastically in terms
of my playing uh I haven't been doing
anything really spectacular but I
haven't been making too many mistakes
let's say at the end I made many but
before that uh and that's usually enough
to have a very good result so I'll keep
on trying to do
that okay this next question is for Leon
um being an Armenian chess player in
Armenia having a rich history of Chess
and really it being a um a very integral
part of the culture what is it like
playing in a country where you're
recognized just walking down the street
and all of your uh um uh fellow
Armenians are following your games and
watching and cheering you on do you feel
added pressure from that do you feel um
uh that that you owe your fans then
something
well uh as
a more or less a good player
I not more and not less not counting my
play in the single cup I have to say
that I get the luxury of you know being
congratulated being cheered for but of
course it has the downside when I have a
terrible tournament everybody comes to
me and just starts swearing
[Laughter]
and I I had this one guy this is a funny
story this this one guy I know who loves
to make some
bets so I had this
ridiculous tournaments more ridiculous
than here actually surprise surprise in
in the candidates this
year so uh the guy approaches me and he
says well if you were going to lose on
purpose why didn't you tell me you
know I made bets on you you know I've
lost a lot of
money so yeah that's that's the that's
the
downside okay our next
question Jay Stallings with Coach J's
chess Academy um I'm I'm a chess coach
and uh my uh my students always look up
to you guys and has great role models um
we saw in this tournament velin toal
love start out 0 and2 and and had a
great tournament after that um played
very well um and we also see saw that
some of you had uh tournaments that
you're not happy with um how do you
recover uh from from an 0 and2 start and
how do you recover from a tournament
that's that's not your best tournament
to come back strong in the next event if
if vesselin and um anybody El who feels
like uh they need to come back can can
mention an answer thank
you well maybe the advantage of getting
older is that also you use your me
memory
so next day you just
forget uh this question is addressed to
Fabiano uh during the seventh round uh
Maurice interviewed Mr
singfield and he said that if you keep
your winning ways we may have to change
your name to Bobby Karana or Fabiano
Fisher uh which name would you
prefer um yeah I think that's a bit too
soon yeah okay in terms of uh Bobby's
Fisher's best performances I mean
he it's way out of whatever League I I
demonstrated in this tournament um his
uh his demolition of of Larson and tonov
and
petan uh and spasy was uh you know one
of the most uh remarkable things in
chess history um so I don't think I'm
anywhere near that yet but uh in any
case he's an inspiration so
uh uh yeah any someone to look up to um
and yeah maybe in the future I'll uh
play a bit more like
him okay our next question comes from
our chief Arbiter Chris
bird hey guys
uh I have a question for all of you and
Prof like to go on records said thank
you um for giving me a front row seat to
watch uh this exciting tournament giving
me 30 maybe 29 exciting really exciting
games of
Chess anyway but so a a question to
everyone if if you had to pick your own
standing with Caro if you had to pick
what you consider to be the best game
that was played in this event uh which I
yourself included you can choose your
own game or any of the others which game
would it be well I didn't play any good
games here from my side so um I would
probably have to say the game between
Fabiano and Maxim when Fabiano is white
in the car pond that just a great
preparation oh for sure
it's any of his
Victor
remember there too
many
um well I was surprised by your question
I thought you were going to apologize
for the many questionable tweets you
made from the
Orit
um no I I actually um really liked
Fabiano's game from uh from the first
round with westline
um not W's greatest game but a very U
very nice uh effective Display of Power
chess um yeah I'm I'm not sure
uh I sort of enjoyed all of my games
even the ones uh which I didn't win um
they were all pretty
exciting I'm not sure which was my my
best game but okay uh in any case they
were all fun to
play Max yeah well of course I'm going
to pick a game from
Fabiano I'm just not I've been thinking
about it while the players wereing but I
still don't really know
so
maybe uh maybe it's first game against
Magnus because
from what what I I was looking like it
seemed like dangerous and he came up
with the best defensive moves and then
the best attacking moves some night D3
shot I think was extremely
impressive yeah I was impressed by that
game as well because it looks
beautiful excellent we have time for one
more question and do we have anybody in
the audience that would like to do the
honors
Rex you got a question okay I want to
ask the five players other than aaro
when are you going to move to St
Louis put you in a good place maybe if I
could rephrase the question just a
little bit uh as you know obviously
thanks to the sing Fields there is this
Resurgence of Chess in the United States
um it seems that uh many chess players
including vishaan have decided to move
to Europe due to the proximity of all
the major events as you see more and
more tournaments like these in the
United States do you think top players
like yourselves or others would consider
the United States as their home
base I uh I heard um when I was here
that um for some reason uh the um
population of St Louis is is shrinking
and I don't really get why uh so I guess
um by moving here we would uh we would
solve that
problem okay I want to thank all the
players very much for joining us at this
press conference you have been amazing
SP and I'd like to remind our audience
that they should tune in tomorrow for
the ultimate moves and uh follow us on
uschess champs.com I'm sorry Monday
thank you and follow us on uschess
champs.com on Tuesday uh we'll be having
The Ultimate Showdown a match between
hikaro Nakamura Lavana ronian in chess
960 thank you all very much and we look
forward to seeing you again at the 2015
singfield
C
[Music]
welcome to the 2014 singfield cup the
strongest chess tournament in
history it looks as though Carana has
wrapped up the gate and topov resigned
pretty sweet start for the youngest
player in our tournament sort of similar
to the Norway chess tournament he won
his first two games before he ran out of
steam and and lost a couple games I
think it's a great start but I have to
stay vigilant till the end it's going to
be all over quite soon Magnus Carlson is
losing he played a line that does not
work world champion Magnus Carlson in
disarray looking at the board god with
his head in his hands we don't
unbelievable he cannot believe what has
taking place here in the third round the
S
cup my play was not so great today but
let's not draw too many conclusions
yet there's nothing else to say about
this tournament right now except Fabiano
Fabiano Fabiano Fabiano caruana 7 and0
in the S field cup if Magnus was doing
it we wouldn't be so surprised I guess
um but for me it's pretty unusual we
have our singfield Cup champion Fabiano
Carana Fabiano's playing he's playing
proper chess it's an amazing result it
will be one of the greatest results
[Music]
ever
e